Okay,
boom,
and we're live.
How are you?
Welcome to the show.
I'm doing great Jeff.
Thanks for her rehab.
Close.
There you go.
I know you've done a podcast for.
You did Tim Ferriss podcast.
I heard you on that.
Actually three of them.
I think I did for three.
Three really cast.
Oh,
I need to listen to the other two then.
What is this one you brought me?
Man,
this is crazy.
That is.
Do you think I'm a drunk?
This is what.
This is.
Maybe the dry farm wines.
Guys think that this giant magnum.
I'd have to have a party.
It's a,
it's a wine that's pretty legit in
regards to if you want to stay on a
ketogenic diet.
And a,
I tested this in my office actually and
just found that to be.
It's non glycaemic for one thing,
which means it doesn't impact the sugar
content is so low.
There's not an elevation in blood
glucose and uh,
I can stay in Ketosis on this one if I
do one glass two or three.
Three starts to kick me out.
But to glasses of wine,
you can completely stay in Ketosis.
Most glasses,
most wine will kick you out of Ketosis.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean it's highly dependent on like a
merlow.
A dry wine typically doesn't,
but a smart little more dry,
uh,
most of it,
yeah,
most of the time.
Yeah.
A white wines tend to kick me out more.
And of course something like a sweet
wine,
we'll go bowling or something like that.
Really sweet.
Uh,
St Maria,
you know,
that'll take you out very fast.
Just sugar.
And even beer does,
even though it's supposed to be low carb
beer tends to kick me out.
Really Michelob ultra and maybe one,
you know,
one or two.
But other than that,
yeah,
I mean I get that question a lot so it
actually got me interested in studying
this so I can answer some of the
questions with some level of knowledge
and after testing these wines and uh,
I came to the conclusion,
yeah,
you can drink two glasses of wine a day
on a strict ketogenic diet.
And I think this is important for people
that are doing it to manage their health
long term and um,
especially people with actual health
issues were ketogenic diet,
ketogenic diet benefits them,
like epileptic.
Absolutely.
Like when I got into this,
it was a pediatric epilepsy like in 2007
or eight and now the applications are
expanding,
you know,
a dozen or more.
So we hold a conference and Metabolic
Therapeutics Conference where the top
tier people in academia and like from
Johns Hopkins,
they probably one of the spearheaded
ketogenic diet application clinically
and a top tier scientists from Yale and
Harvard and other places,
uh,
present here.
And it's,
I think the applicate it was like 11 or
12 applications for the key to genic
diet where there's good peer reviewed
research to support the efficacy,
uh,
as a metabolic based therapy for a
number of everything from,
you know,
polycystic ovary syndrome to acne to
rare.
Even genetic disorders like Angelman
Syndrome is something that we're
studying,
a,
it's a,
it's a genetic disorder where a
housekeeping gene is mutated and it
results in seizures and a motor function
impairment and the ketogenic diet is
remarkably effective.
Uh,
not.
It's really drug resistant seizures that
these kids have,
and even in the presence of a persistent
molecular pathology,
a genetic pathology,
the key to genic diet,
uh,
through altering metabolism with the
Diet,
you can largely silenced the pathology
and the motor function impairments
associated with this disease.
And that,
that's amazing to me that you have a
disease that is persistently there due
to a genetic mutation and you can
largely silence the symptoms that is
yours
in the interest of addressing people
that are probably on the ground floor.
And I feel like there's very few people
today that don't understand what a
ketogenic diet is,
but just in case for people who don't
know,
there are people that use carbohydrates
mainly for fuel.
And then there's the mutagenic diet
which makes your body run on fats and
ketones.
So try just kind of explain that to
people,
like how this came about.
Um,
how people started to,
uh,
researching this and how you got
involved.
Okay.
Uh,
I mean this goes back to if not
centuries,
millennia,
you know,
dating,
back to the time of hypocrisy when it
was observed that fasting was a quote
unquote cure for seizures and with the
observation.
Yeah.
So fasting puts you into fasting
Ketosis,
right?
So even intermittent fasting,
like I do the 14 hour thing where I,
hours,
you know,
that's,
that's clinic.
I mean technically that's kind of,
I call that semi a semi fasted state
when you achieve that,
you know,
when you're eating breakfast,
it could be 12 hours or more a you've
eaten last and you're breaking the fast
essentially.
But with severe epileptic patients,
uh,
it was found that when you,
when they restricted food and in some
cases water after about two or three
days,
you had profound seizure control or it
silenced even the worst seizures.
And this was observed,
uh,
you know,
for Millennia,
like I said,
and uh,
the,
there was some work done in the,
the early 19 hundreds and 19 twenties.
Uh,
there was some work done at the Mayo
Clinic that I observed the presence of
these ketone bodies and people that were
eating a carbohydrate restricted diet
that was primarily a based on eating fat
and with a minimal amount of protein
just enough to ensure there's not
protein malnutrition.
And it was observed that there was an
elevation of ketone bodies,
Beta hydroxy butyrate acetate in the
blood.
So they called it a physiologist called
it the key to genic diet.
Uh,
even technically,
maybe Beta hydroxy butyrate is not a
ketone,
but physiologists called these ketone
bodies,
Beta hydroxybutyrate acetate and
acetone,
and it mimics the physiological state of
fasting in many ways.
So if you were to draw blood off someone
on a ketogenic diet,
it would sort of look like they had been
fasting a few days,
uh,
because it's mimicking the way I think
about it.
It's suppressing the hormone insulin and
kind of mimicking the fuel,
the substrate utilization that you would
be using in a state of being fasted,
which is primarily fats,
ketones.
And,
uh,
to a lesser extent a of,
I mean,
a glucose from amino acids from protein.
You are mobilizing some gluconeogenic
amino acids from your skeletal muscle
when you are fasting.
Ketones are protein sparing though,
so they are anti catabolic in that way.
So because we make ketones and our large
brain has a massive demand for energy
and the ketones fulfill that for the
most part.
When fasting,
uh,
it prevents us from breaking down
muscle.
Uh,
it prevents us from liberating the
gluconeogenic amino acids that would
otherwise be chewed up and use to
maintain our glucose levels.
So the ketones sort of replaced the
glucose.
The brain has the metabolic flexibility
to adapt from using glucose to using
primarily ketone bodies in those ketone
bodies really have a protein sparing.
Anti catabolic.
No.
Is this an ancient system that was in
place back when people,
you know,
obviously couldn't go to the store and
your diet varied depending upon what was
available and it just allowed people
like say,
like maybe inuits that lived off a lot
of fats because they really don't have
many carbohydrates.
If you're living off a whale blubber and
things along those lines like they had
to back then.
Yeah.
Uh,
I mean it's hardwired in,
in humans and other animals.
My,
my wife Studies Manta rays and uh,
and they,
they're the,
like the Einsteins of the sea that,
so they're the fish with the biggest
brains of all animals and we've done
metabolomic studies on them and looking
at the blood and they produce a
significant amount of ketones,
like two millimolar,
uh,
they dive really deep so it may help
protect them from that.
So yeah,
animals will go into ketosis during
fasting or even if you manipulate their
food source,
uh,
the Quito pet sanctuary actually treats
dogs that have cancer and they implement
a key to genic diet in dogs,
uh,
in addition to some other things to
help.
Uh,
and the many of these are our dogs from
kill shelters and,
and put them on an anticancer therapy
program and they can get into ketosis
for the most harder.
But most of them,
most dog food is not kidogenic is like
documents have grain in it,
right?
Yeah.
For fillers and things along those
lines.
Yeah,
it's really interesting.
I was talking with,
uh,
Ron Pena,
yesterday,
uh,
from quest nutrition.
The CEO of quest nutrition and he
brought to my attention that if you look
on a package of dog food,
you won't see carbohydrates listed even
though it's the primary because there
was some laws or policy put into action
to prevent carbohydrates from even being
listed on kibble on dog food,
which I find,
you know,
there's a lot of reasons why mostly
because dogs really shouldn't be eating
a carbohydrate based diet and that's
probably part of the reason,
but there's sort of other reasons why a.
But it's really important that the.
So the food that the Quito pet sanctuary
gives the dogs that have cancer and they
confirmed that they have cancer with a,
a glucose pet scan and they do it,
you know,
before,
during and after is basically kind of
like a raw foods key to genic diet
that's almost completely restricted in
what we've called glycemic
carbohydrates.
Things that would elevate the glucose
levels and it's very high in fat,
relatively speaking.
Yeah.
But dogs,
you know,
really should not be eating any grains
at all.
Yeah.
I feed my dog grain free dog food,
but I don't know if it's carbon free.
I don't know what's in there is a kibble
kibble.
It's hard to find out.
Right?
Yeah.
Uh,
I mean,
you know,
dog food that has a,
like some peas and sweet potatoes and
things like that.
It is.
Okay.
Uh,
but ideally,
you know,
you want to give your dog like a whole
food nutrition just like humans and you
know,
they say don't give your dog human food,
but that's,
there's no evidence for that.
And uh,
you know,
I've given talks where I talked about
giving dogs raw food and there was a,
there'd be a reaction from the audience
while it's dangerous to give your dog
like raw food or what do they in a
while,
you know,
I mean if the,
if it's ground beef that's been sitting
around at a processing plant for a while
yet maybe,
but fresh,
you know,
a meat from a butcher,
fresh meat.
I mean,
it's probably the ideal thing for a dog.
Ideally,
organ meats like liver,
heart,
kidneys,
things like that.
Grind it up.
Uh,
you know,
and some,
some Greens tos and things like spinach
you can buy like spinach powder.
So the Quito pet sanctuary has an ebook
that's completely free if you go to
Quito,
pet sanctuary,
a.org,
I believe,
and you can download the Ebook and it
tells you very precisely how to make
your dog food not only to,
to,
you know,
if your dog has cancer,
but to maximize its overall performance
and you are preventing cancer by virtue
of putting them on a diet that optimizes
your,
their metabolic health.
Well that's got to be very difficult to
package though.
And something that's sort of evergreen.
So it's on the shelf and paper bag.
You can rip open and just pour into a
bowl.
That's what everybody wants,
like this convenience thing,
but there is a way to do it.
And uh,
you know,
I know,
I know those guys,
you know,
epigenics a foundation,
they,
uh,
are,
are working.
They basically support the Quito pet
sanctuary and they're working out not
only the macronutrient ratios that need
to go into the food,
but also the types of food and also
being able to package it in a way to
ultimately come up with a food that you
can go.
It may not be on the shelf and probably
ideally shouldn't be on the shelf,
but it will be like in the refrigerator
section of your pet food store.
So you go there and like for our dogs we
get like a tube of freshly ground up,
a steak or whatever.
And we feed that.
We take the ground me and mix it with
Oregon,
me and mix it with a different greens,
Broccoli and things like that and give
it to them.
And they love it.
We put a little bit of coconut oil on it
sometimes.
So you would go to the grocery store or
it would be,
could be shipped to your house.
And it's basically kept refrigerated and
it has the compliment of like organ
meats to,
you know,
the proper types of fats,
a official hill,
fats and fiber.
And um,
and it fits that macronutrient ratio,
the ketogenic diet dog was horrific
farts.
One of them that,
yeah,
we have a great Dane.
They're both rescue dogs.
Uh,
one of them does Broccoli,
organ meats and coconut oil.
I'm like,
Whoa,
go room.
Yeah,
it's either my wife,
uh,
or uh,
the dog,
I don't know.
She might be blaming the dog,
maybe blame the dog.
They're healthy.
How long have you been involved in
ketogenic research and research on Keto
diets?
And,
and how long have you been doing it
yourself?
Yeah,
I guess it was.
I got turned onto it in 2007 or eight.
And,
uh,
actually I was communicating online,
on a nutrition forum on a fitness
website.
And uh,
I was a neuroscientist.
I did my phd on cellular neuroscience.
I didn't let something called patch
clamp electrophysiology where I
electrically record from neurons and it
was,
you know,
really,
uh,
mostly just neuroscience and my
postdoctoral research was studying
seizures and uh,
I got to the point where we're doing
some drug based research on seizures and
other types of research and the types of
seizures that I study are powerful tonic
clonic seizures that a navy seal could
potentially experience using closed
circuit rebreather.
So when they're underwater,
a limitation for their time underwater
is cns oxygen toxicity and it's also
limitation for hyperbaric oxygen
therapy,
rebreathers or those ones that don't
emit bubbles.
Is that correct?
Yeah.
So there's a bit of a stealth component,
so you're underwater and if you're going
over a lake to uh,
engage the enemy,
they can't see you coming.
So that's the advantage that they're
very,
um,
stealth,
like a,
the disadvantages that at 50 feet of
seawater in just 10 minutes,
you have the potential to get cns oxygen
toxicity.
Of course,
if you follow the guidelines and dive
within the guidelines,
uh,
of you know,
the depth and the time,
then you're typically okay.
90 nine point nine percent of the time,
but if you have,
you know,
a,
uh,
someone shooting with a 50 caliber
machine gun on,
into the water,
you're not going to want to come up,
you know,
you're going to want to stay down there.
If you have a mind to go down to the
bridge or ship or something,
you have to likely,
in many cases go down below 50 feet and
it puts you at the potential of having a
seizure and a seizure under water.
The seizure itself is not a,
a deadly per se,
but having a seizure under water could
be fatal to the mission and in,
you know,
the warfighter.
So,
uh,
my research was really developing
various technologies where we actually
put things inside of Microsoft,
uh,
inside a hyperbaric chamber,
like an atomic force microscope or a
laser scanning confocal or we can look
at the Mitochondria under pressures that
simulate these operational conditions.
And,
uh,
and that was about 10 years ago,
and out of that research evolved
studying various things and looking at
the cells and even the Mitochondria and
observing that ketones essentially
enhance brain energy production.
And resilience in extreme environments
of high pressure and high oxygen.
And from those cellular studies,
uh,
I became more interested in what people
do when drugs don't work for epilepsy.
And I looked up and found the ketogenic
diet and uh,
this fits in perfect because my
background was studying nutrition and I
was studying pharmacology at the time,
but it allowed me to bring nutrition
back into my research program,
uh,
and studying the ketogenic diet
specifically.
And the program officer at the time at
the office of navy research really liked
the idea of the ketogenetic diet and a
drug.
So being able to consume something that
can elevate these blood ketone levels
which can cross the blood brain barrier
and make our brains kind of super brains
under physiological extremes.
So that's what I really.
I put my efforts into studying the
ketogenic diet and also into developing
and testing a wide range of exonerations
ketone products and which come,
which are on the spectrum of drug like
to,
on the spectrum of kind of natural based
things that can be combined together
that put you in a state of therapeutic
ketosis within like 30 minutes to 60
minutes so you can use it right before
an operation,
a for mission or therapeutically.
So if you have a child,
for example,
that has status epilepticus,
which is continuous seizures that you
can't stop instead of giving them an
anti epilepsy drug that can have side
effects and even developmental delays.
Uh,
the Ketogenic Diet,
you know,
it takes 24,
48,
maybe 72 hours to work,
but if you can tube feed them a,
a,
a ketone supplement and put them into
therapeutic ketosis,
then you can mitigate these seizures
which could have potential longterm
effects.
So that's just one example of a
therapeutic application of exogenous
ketones.
But,
so you're doing the research on this and
you decided to start doing it yourself?
Yeah,
I started doing it myself to get a
better understanding.
Actually the,
there was a patient in in the UK,
his name is Mike Dancer,
and if you just kind of Google Mike
Dancer and epilepsy,
you'll come up on his story,
which is a really remarkable story
because he tried a dozen,
half dozen,
maybe even a dozen different types of
antiepileptic drugs and high doses,
things like Keppra,
like things that are the standard of
care and it didn't work for him.
He connected with me and I,
I mentioned a couple supplements before
I embarked on the Ketogenic Diet.
And long story short,
I gave him the information kind of
here's the key to genic diet.
Here's a scientific rationale.
It looks like before you go and have
brain surgery,
they were going to remove part of his
hippocampus.
Well,
uh,
I said,
you know,
just use this as a,
maybe about 2008 or nine ish.
And a long story short,
I didn't talk to them because they got
really busy.
I transitioned into a tenure track
assistant professor position.
I was working very long hours,
maybe four months or so,
went by,
and then when I contacted him he was
like,
I have not had a seizure in this time
and he was having multiple seizures
sometimes per day and couldn't leave the
house and it was almost like a proof of
concept and it also caused pretty
significant body composition changes in
him and he was in the fitness industry
and even did a bodybuilding show.
So he basically was,
it saved.
It saved his life actually because he
had what,
what I would call and what the doctors
called terminal epilepsy.
There was no way to control seizures and
when,
when the drugs failed,
the ketogenic diet worked for him.
And that was almost like proof of
concept I'm reading.
I thought the qg Hank Diet was kind of
like this fad diet.
I just knew about it in the fitness
circles is something that I would
actually typically avoid.
But when you read about the history of
the Diet in the 19 twenties,
early 19 twenties,
and how Dr Wilder kind of developed this
therapy,
uh,
at Mayo clinic there's like really
legit.
A peer reviewed research behind it and
enormous amount of research and I
realized it was a grossly underutilized,
you know,
mega bought what I would call a
metabolic based therapy for seizures.
Why would you typically avoid?
Because they're in our healthcare
systems,
there's really not the infrastructure
when a patient comes in and uh,
and they have uncontrollable seizures.
The neurologists or epileptologist
typically does not have the skillset in
nutrition knowledge in nutrition to be
able to guide a patient successfully
into nutritional ketosis and to do that
so they would have to refer them to a
registered dietician,
which typically are not savvy and
ketogenic diets.
Uh,
but,
uh,
but now the Charlie Foundation is a
foundation that worked closely with
Johns Hopkins and I think there's about
150 to 200 clinics worldwide,
uh,
that are key to genic diet clinics that
have,
you know,
registered dieticians that are working
to assist patients.
So now,
you know,
uh,
the infrastructure is kind of there,
but doctors typically will prescribe a
drug whenever they can.
And even when they know they may,
most of them are probably aware that,
you know,
it is the standard of care,
a drank diet is a standard of care when,
when drugs fail and there's things like
vagal nerve stimulation and other
things.
But the ketogenic diet has been around
so long,
it has an amazing track record.
There are some side effects associated
with it,
mostly associated with a classical Kj
Diet,
which was like 90 percent fat,
eight percent protein.
But now,
uh,
Eric Kossoff at Johns Hopkins has done a
lot of work on what I would call the
modified ketogenic diet.
He calls it the modified Atkins Diet,
which is more liberal and protein.
It's 20 to 30 percent protein and the
balance being mostly fats from healthy
sources and the carbohydrates are just,
you know,
completely non glycemic carbohydrates
you'd get from salads or green
vegetables and things like that.
And what are those side effects?
Uh,
so with the classical Qj Diet,
they found that kids put on the Diet it
a reduced igf one,
which if you're into longevity,
that's,
that might be a good thing,
right?
Uh,
and it reduced their terminal height in
some cases because of the protein
restriction.
So restricting protein can,
uh,
for reasons we know in the longevity
field,
you know,
uh,
reduce,
igf one signaling insulin,
igf one signaling,
and that was found to be the case in
kids versus the suspected mechanism.
But when protein was titrated back in,
uh,
that was not the case.
So there's also kidney stones can happen
and there was a supplement potassium
citrate that can help kind of offset the
mild metabolic acidosis that occurs when
you go in the ketogenic diet and just
simply,
I mean,
you could do that nutritionally just by
formula in your diet and using more
salt,
uh,
to balance out and using more minerals.
So actually the big issue was just the
protein just yeah,
I think the protein and for kids that
are growing and developing and uh,
and if you restrict protein and kids
that have all these growth factors and
everything that really kind of require
a.
and also if you go on the Ketogenic Diet
it,
you may be inadvertently limiting total
calories just because of the
palatability of the.
Especially the classical Qj Diet,
whereas the modified Atkins Diet,
which was studied very rigorously at
Johns Hopkins by Eric Kossoff,
has shown to have like 90 percent of the
benefits of this draconian,
a classic ketogenic diet and a when
possible,
you know,
it's better to put.
And that's what I follow.
I follow a modified Atkins,
which is just higher in protein.
So let's,
let's establish the protocol.
So the step,
the classic Ketogenic Diet is 90 percent
fat.
Eight percent protein,
two percent carbs.
Is that what it is?
Uh,
that's about the macronutrient ratios.
Yeah.
And they call it a clinically,
they call it the four to one or the
three to one ketogenic diet.
And that's really confusing because that
four to one is in grams,
right?
So it's a,
it's actually like four parts fat to one
part protein and carbohydrates,
carbohydrates being very,
very small part of that one,
that four to one ratio.
And if three to one ratio would be,
and that would be like 92 percent fat,
I mean it's really high.
And then the three to one ratio is like
88 percent fat or close to 85 percent
fat.
So I like to do it.
It's,
it's,
it's better,
it's more,
it's more easy for me to consider in
terms of percentage of calories.
And um,
and about 75 percent calories from fat
is pretty doable and pretty palatable.
So that's how you do it.
Yeah.
Sixty five to 70 percent if it's super
important for people,
uh,
not only in the clinical realm,
but also people that are doing this,
you know,
for athletic reasons,
for losing body fat,
managing type two diabetes is probably
the biggest,
the low hanging fruit of all these
applications.
And I can talk more about that.
Uh,
the biggest thing to do is to count your
macros and test your ketones of course.
But people are horrible at counting how
many calories they are getting in when
you tell them to follow a diet.
So they really need a,
a,
an APP,
a software program,
a,
an APP,
and a Avatar.
Nutrition makes the kind of gold
standard app for tracking your macros.
And I'm working with them hopefully to
develop,
it's called avatar nutrition.
That's the actual app name that is the
APP name.
And that's a,
it's a very highly innovative,
a app that not only does it,
you know,
you put in your macro has,
it's a macro calculator,
those,
that macro nutrient profile is in the
system and you do body composition
measurements a weekly and it calculates
through what I would call an artificial
intelligence system and ai system in the
algorithm to,
to adjust your calories week by week
based on the progress that you're
making.
And uh,
and it's the only system that I know of.
It's kind,
that's a,
like a macro tracking system that also
gives you feedback on how to titrate
your calories and your macros over time
to hit specific body composition changes
that you want to get.
And this is the system.
It's the ideal platform to,
uh,
incorporate the ketogenic diet into.
So it's gonna take some work with the,
you know,
the guys that are writing software to
design it.
But essentially,
you know,
you'll have available a key to genic
diet app that we'll be able to adjust to
whatever output that you want,
whether it be managing seizures,
uh,
maybe a metabolic management of cancer
or,
you know,
body composition changes or performance
changes over time.
And that's all being written up.
Now.
I've got a bunch of questions.
First of all,
what do you,
what,
what are your primary fats like when
you,
when,
when you tell someone that your diet is,
I mean,
forget about the classic 90 percent fat,
but even 75 percent fat people just go.
Jesus,
like where?
Where's all that fat coming from?
Like what you,
what do you use for fats and do vary it.
Yeah.
Um,
my,
my dad is pretty.
I get the same 12 to 15 foods probably
pretty much every week.
My wife kind of eats outside of the
range of the Ketogenic Diet.
So sometimes,
or she.
Yeah.
How dare she?
Uh,
I don't try to pasta in front of you and
mock you a she does,
but I don't crave it.
So that's the thing.
And she thinks it's really strange.
I mean,
Italian,
I am,
so that created a bit of a problem with
my family,
like when I go home,
yeah,
I was up on pasta so you might.
Carbohydrate tolerance is actually
really good.
So if I go back to a higher carb diet,
uh,
you know,
I can't throw in three,
400 grams of carbs a day,
but I tolerate it very well.
So me going into a ketogenetic diet was
a very strange thing for me to do that.
Uh,
I had read Robb Wolfe's book and knew
about the Paleo Diet and uh,
and even,
uh,
some,
some of the writings of Gary Taubes,
but I was a little hesitant or skeptical
about about it and skeptical.
Well,
I really thought that you need carbs to
grow in the gym and maintain your
strength and uh,
and performance.
And I just felt that the brain needs
glucose for fuel and I didn't,
you know,
I was kind of unaware of the research
that was done in Harvard in 1967,
uh,
by George Cahill.
And I did get a chance to talk to him
for a pastor.
Rob Wolf is,
you know,
rob is really into Jujitsu,
right?
He's having an issue with maintaining a
strict ketogenic diet.
I don't know if he's going with the
classical ketogenic or the modified
Atkins,
but he has a problem with having the,
the carbohydrate restriction when he has
really hard training days.
Yeah,
I would to,
I,
I've talked to rob about that a little
bit.
Uh,
the body is incredibly adaptable to
switching fuel sources and adapting to
that fuel source over time.
And some people may be a little less
adaptable than other people,
but I think that if he was to give it a,
I think you knowing rob,
he did give it a very legit shot.
He may benefit from adding some slow
carbs in just prior to an intra workout.
During what's up?
What do you consider a slow carb?
Uh,
you know,
there are supplements out there,
but yeah,
if we're going to talk about,
uh,
I would say yeah,
maybe a little bit of sweet potato in,
you know,
prior to training or the day before,
maybe a few hours before.
So it's some sort of a car with a plenty
of fiber or something like a digest
slowly the idea,
even a high molecular weight,
carbohydrates that are on the market
now,
what are the,
um,
you know,
I don't use them anymore.
I know Jeff Bullock has a product out,
uh,
you can,
I think you can.
Starch is the name of it and it just,
uh,
you know,
it will slightly elevate your glucose
and not trigger an insulin response so
you won't go hypoglycemic after and
it'll just,
you know,
essentially,
titrating carbohydrates and glucose into
your system over a predetermined period,
you know,
so they know that you're a,
it'll kind of hit your system and
sustain it for three or four hours,
which is ideal for people engaging in,
you know,
a,
an,
a or cycling during that,
during that timeframe.
But I think,
I mean if you're getting in a sufficient
amount of calories and if you are using
things like creatine monohydrate,
which knows where you work through the
foster gen system,
you are able to generate atp for those
short bursts of power that you need to
manage your opponent and sustain it.
So for a supplementation,
if we're going to stop my creatine,
would you do that prior to the workout?
Would like know a lot of people take
creatine,
postworkout?
Yeah.
I just,
uh,
you know,
if you're tickling pre attentive.
Yeah.
And you stopped taking,
created it's in your system for,
you know,
a couple of days to a week or more.
So it's just,
you know,
on a daily basis doesn't matter
necessarily when you take it.
It's just that you take it on a and
probably at least three grams per day
for a larger guy at three to five grams
per day.
Is that something you take a,
it's one of the few supplements that I
take.
I only take maybe three or four
supplement.
I used to take all these different
supplements so I'm more of a food guy.
Uh,
but maybe I'd take three or four
supplements and they use some of the new
food products that are coming out on the
market now,
a junk food products and that allows me
to maintain my kid drank diet when I'm
traveling.
Do you ever mess around with Beta
Alanine?
Yeah.
Uh,
it's something I use to increase a
carnosine levels,
right?
It's something that I used in the past.
I don't like the tingles that I get a
lot of people like to tinker with them
and it's not quite that extreme.
It's like Niacin,
but it's working through a different
receptor.
Yeah.
The first time I took notice and I
thought I was going to die,
but yeah,
it's unpleasant.
It's not something that,
you know,
some people look forward to it.
I don't know,
those people are strange,
but the Beta Alanine is a good.
Makes me uncomfortable.
But I remember drinking on the way to
the gym.
It was part of my preworkout formula.
Um,
and it just made me itchy.
It's didn't like it.
And you know that the data's not dance a
little bit.
It's not.
I wouldn't,
it's not what I would call compelling,
but it looks like it may offer a
benefit.
It was just recommended to me.
That's why I brought it up.
So you're creating three grams per day
and what do you that up to 15,
something like that.
What?
He was on the mark.
I would go to the.
I lost some weight or yeah,
that was like almost almost exactly.
So I had a couple of weeks ago I got
down,
I did an a mission with NASA and I was
underwater for a while and when it came
back up,
how long is awhile?
Uh,
I was under for 10 days,
which is Christ.
That's more than a while.
It makes me an aquanaut yeah.
Wow.
That's crazy.
So,
and during that time,
during the training for it,
I was doing a lot of swimming,
which was a,
I sink like a rock.
I'm kind of negatively buoyant and so it
took a lot out of me and I tried to get
into my file that I was like closer to
200.
I think maybe you'd be more likely to be
an astronaut candidate for your,
like lower weight and space is a big
thing.
Has Been.
So I tried to get my body weight from
2:26
down to two.
Oh seven.
And I did it,
took about three months and now I'm
creeping slowly back up.
I'm down.
And what did you do to do just high
aerobic workout restriction?
I did intermittent fasting.
Really just transitioned to a diet where
I typically to a ketogenic breakfast
that's kind of small and I would made
that a little bit smaller and two or
three days out of the week,
um,
on average I would just kind of naughty
until dinner and then I would eat a
substantial dinner and then maybe do
some activity after that and then kind
of nibble at nighttime,
maybe an hour or two before bed.
And that was kind of my routine.
So almost like a warrior diet type deal.
Pretty close to that.
Yeah.
From what I know that that's pretty
close to that and I did not in any way
feel deprived of food and that's really,
you know,
people who follow a low carb diet or
ketogenic diet,
they think you don't have to count
macros,
which was like the biggest mistake.
They think you just go on this and you
don't have to count calories,
but you really do.
I mean you could sit back,
you could sit down in front of the TV
with like a bag of cashews and I can
Polish that off pretty quick and you
could do a lot of damage.
Like that's a lot of calories.
Yeah.
It depends on the kind of foods that
you're eating.
Two handfuls of almonds I think is like
500 calories or something.
Yeah.
That's like,
that doesn't even make sense.
Yeah.
So I talked to people who follow the
Diet and they're like,
the huge one diet doesn't work for me.
I got on it and I gained like three
pounds and I was like,
well,
what was your calories?
What was your macros?
Oh,
I have no idea.
I don't.
I was told I don't,
I'll have to count that,
you know,
that's the most important thing.
So this is the function of the APP I
told you about Avatar,
which is kind of a macro counting
program.
Uh,
right now you can set the adjustments to
do low carb,
but uh,
the,
once the software is written up to,
uh,
for the Quito option,
that will be a tremendous resource for
people.
The average person that wants to do the
occasion Hank Diet and hopefully we're
going to craft it in a way to,
to,
to help the,
uh,
the clinical community too.
It's one of the reasons why I wanted to
have you on is because you're an actual
scientist and this is,
there's so many misconceptions when it
comes to ketogenic diet,
at the benefits,
the problems associated with it.
And there's a bunch of people that.
One of the things that I've found really
fascinating is recently because the
ketogenic diet has become so popular,
there's been these sort of sparsely
educated meathead trainer type dudes
that are pulling the ketogenic diet.
And whenever I see that happen,
I go,
oh,
here's a person whose ideas are
threatened and you know,
like whenever someone says the Ketogenic
Diet is not beneficial or it's not
really worth it,
I'm like,
okay,
but you're not saying anything like
where's the science like point to
something because there's a substantial
amount of science that shows the benefit
of the key to genic diet.
But there's a lot of meat heads that
are,
that have been critical of it.
And when I,
when I read that,
I'm like,
okay,
you're not saying anything.
Like there's no substantial reason why
you're critical of it.
This makes me think that you have been
pushing a certain type of diet for a
long time.
This comes along,
it shows contrary evidence and trying to
diminish it in some sort of a way,
but without any actual science.
So what have been the criticisms of the
Ketogenic Diet and how many of them are
actually valid in terms of when,
when what I'm talking about when I'm
talking to people,
especially if I'm talking to
professional athletes,
I'm talking to athletes who's very
health is very critical that they have
energy,
right?
We were talking about fighters.
So for them like to recommend a
ketogenic diet to a fighter,
it's very tricky because we,
you're talking like one percent,
two percent performance could be the
difference between victory and defeat
and maybe even being knocked out or
submitted and being successful.
Yeah,
so I think most important people need to
appreciate that when you transition your
body from burning carbohydrates and
glucose and forcing it to rely primarily
all fat and ketones for fuel or not.
It's not one or the other,
but you're shifting for the predominant
fuel source to be fat and ketones.
And that's not happening.
That's not something that happens like
overnight and it doesn't even happen in
two or three weeks.
So what I've seen in elite level,
cyclist and and other types of sports is
that it really takes a minimum of three
months,
ideally six months and even after a year
I think you're getting a changes even at
the epigenetic level.
We know that ketones function as a
signaling molecule through histone
deacetylase activity that it's actually
turning on genes that are causing
adaptations in our body and these,
these happened slowly over time.
The more you follow the huge hank diet,
the easier it gets because there's a
learning curve to to implementing it,
but the more you follow it,
the easier it gets and the more benefits
you derive from it over time and those
benefits really don't start to emerge.
The benefits that that I'm thinking
about after about two or three months
and you're talking about benefits on a
cellular level,
not a performance from a performance
level,
a minimum of two months,
like your performance will go down.
So you have to accept,
I mean this is something that voters
would have to do in the off season.
Athletes.
I was stunned at how much of an impact
it had on me.
I mean,
how fast were the benefits?
Well,
the benefits of the weight loss was
pretty,
pretty significant.
Pretty quickly.
I lost a few pounds within the first
week or two,
whereas I'm pretty active and it's not,
you know,
it didn't change much other than that.
Um,
but what I was amazed at like the Keto
flu,
you know,
what people call the Keto flu.
Did you get that dragging for the first
week or two?
Like I was just dry and I would do a
hard workout.
I was like,
oh my God,
I don't know how to keep doing that.
Yeah,
okay.
That's like a big one was hitting the
bag.
That's what I would really feel it
because uh,
you know,
I do rounds or I'll,
I'll set,
you know,
like a,
a certain amount of rounds,
a certain amount of time and that's when
I can really feel the difference from
day to day and I'm just really
struggling.
Yeah.
And how long did it take you to adapt to
that?
Or did you adapt to that?
Like A,
a month in?
It started to
normalize,
but I mean that would be consistent with
the literature if you're looking at
cyclists and if you're,
you know,
a number of different athletes,
it takes about six weeks.
I mean your performance will go down and
then start to creep up back to baseline
at,
around the six week mark and if you
adhere to it strictly and really stick
with your training,
you know,
in the 12 week mark you could be
breaking new pgrs depending on personal
words.
Yeah,
yeah.
Non personal records.
And that's primarily directed to a,
I would say endurance athletes,
ultra marathon athletes to cyclists who
runners too,
you know,
iron man athletes.
Uh,
and the thing that had merged out of all
the emails that I get people sending me
blood work and their performance
measurements is that I used to think it
was about a month or two.
It's more like three months to six
months when they really start hitting
their stride because I think there's
pretty profound changes when you,
when you alter the fuel that you're
giving your body in such a profound way.
Well,
one of the first things that I noticed
the benefit,
one of the first benefits was cognitive
clarity,
um,
lack of fogginess towards the middle of
the day,
the no desire to take a nap and no a
note drop.
Like,
you know,
I would have the,
the big meal thing and then the drop the
valley when you know,
like,
oh,
your body's digesting everything.
And people.
I thought that was just how you lived.
I thought there was no getting around
that.
That's life you eat,
then you get sleepy.
I just,
yeah,
I didn't think that there was any other
options going on.
A ketogenic diet completely changed
that.
And when I would tell people about it,
they're like,
nothing.
I'd be like,
I'm telling you,
there is no difference.
I mean I would eat a meal and go
throughout my day and then it'd be like
4:00
in the afternoon.
I'm like,
where's this crash?
The crash is supposed to be here.
Like,
where's it coming?
No crash.
Yeah.
Same thing with me.
Uh,
I mean looking back at an Undergrad when
I was like task loaded with a lot of
classes and stuff I would make,
I was trying to bulk up at the time and
I would,
I would put like steak or beef on a
Bagel so I would cut a Bagel kind of in
half and put like meat and stuff.
So I would be getting all the carbs from
the Bagel and I would just go get a big
starbucks coffee to,
to mitigate that crash that I would
have.
And now,
so the key to genic diet when you eat a
meal,
it essentially,
if it does not abolish,
is significantly attenuate that insulin
response that you get.
So if you,
you know,
where something like a continuous blood
glucose measurement,
like a dexcon or something,
and you look at that and you eat a,
a standard American diet,
you see a big spike in glucose,
typically in the postprandial glucose,
that'll be hypoglycemic.
And when you do that,
not only does your mental and physical
performance crash,
but you crave food so that we'll send
you,
searching,
sending you,
running to the refrigerator.
Again,
to seek a reward,
to mitigate that,
that dysphoria,
I would say that you get from the
hypoglycemia,
so when you on a Ketogenic Diet,
you essentially abolished that you don't
have this spike in glucose which spikes
insulin and your.
Your energy levels are maintained in.
The big thing is cognitive.
So the cognitive resilience is is a big
thing.
So even if you're hypoglycemic,
you could like use something to lower
your blood glucose,
insulin and push it down to a level that
would put someone into a coma and if
their ketones are elevated,
they are asymptomatic.
For hypoglycemia,
and this was a study actually going back
to the work done by George Cahill at
Harvard where he fasted subjects for 40
days and he did a battery of cognitive
tests and he measured blood going to the
brain and blood coming away from the
brain.
And he determined that about 70 percent
of brain energy metabolism is derived
from ketones when you're fasting.
And the same occurs with a ketogenic
diet too.
So you are literally switching the fuel
source that your brain is using.
But in an extension of the study,
he injected to 20,
I use of Insulin and pushed glucose down
to one millimolar,
uh,
which is universally fatal and everyone,
so you take a crowd of people are eating
a standard diet and push it down to
that,
they'd,
they'd all die.
So none of them died in the study.
I have no idea how they got it passed
the Irb,
the ethics review in Harvard Medical
School.
But they did.
What year was this?
Nineteen 67.
And it was a steady.
I became completely fascinated with
because I couldn't believe that they did
it because you can't even do it in
animals nowadays.
You know,
the IOC committee of the Animal Care and
use committee would,
uh,
would put a stop to that very quick.
You know,
they probably sent the investigator out
of the university if they propose to do
some of the studies that were done.
Uh,
but what they,
when they lowered blood glucose down to
that level,
which would put someone into a coma,
the subjects were asymptomatic for
hypoglycemia because they,
their brains were keto adapted.
They had essentially been over a week
and in a fasted state,
they were all kind of heavyset.
They were divinity students,
uh,
and a few,
I think we're Harvard medical students,
so they tend to be overweight.
So there,
there were liberating a lot of fat from
the adipose and making lots of ketones
and they were in a state where their
brain was tremendously resilient against
hypoglycemia because their ketones were
elevated.
And that has practical implications for
so many different.
And I was reading this and couldn't
believe what I was reading.
I called George Cahill.
We talked about it.
I called all these old time,
you know,
physiologists that were in the field
just to pick their brain.
And they were like thrilled that a young
guy,
you know,
just entering ag,
a tenure track position was going to
like kind of make this as career goes
back a ways.
But I saw all the implications,
not just for epilepsy but for things
like Alzheimer's disease,
traumatic brain injury,
and uh,
a whole host of neurological disorders.
Like there's one in particular called
Glucose transporter type one deficiency
syndrome or glut one deficiency.
And the kids that have this literally
have a deficiency of the glucose
transporter on the blood brain barrier
and their,
their blood glucose is normal,
a normal levels,
but the glucose in their cerebral spinal
fluid is under a two millimolar,
which is,
I mean,
their brains are essentially living in
hypoglycemia.
So they're constantly having seizures.
They can't move a lot of them.
They're confined to a wheelchair.
You put them on a Ketogenic Diet,
uh,
many of them wake up,
they start walking around,
their motor function is reversed.
So it,
the key to genic diet restores brain
energy metabolism in these kids that
can't use glucose as an energy source
with this disorder,
it's called Glucose transporter type one
deficiency syndrome.
And another very interesting example of
a disorder where there is a persistent
molecular pathology where the symptoms
can be largely silenced with the,
the application of a key to genic diet
that needs to be pretty strict.
And that's where ketone supplements come
in.
So I was,
you know,
one,
it's,
it's difficult for some of these kids to
follow occasioning diet.
So like a ketone supplement can
potentially circumvent the dietary
restriction.
That's needed for kidogenic diet and
make it easier for parents and kids to
implement,
but I also think that a ketone
supplement can just further elevate
ketones if you're on a ketogenic diet
and further augment the therapeutic
efficacy of the ketogenic diet or
performance enhancing efficacy.
So my main application is the warfighter
and maybe astronauts do a.
So we just think of it as a way to
augment further,
augment a therapeutic effect or a safety
effect when it comes to divers or
performance effect when it comes to the
warfighters are diverse.
Now when you,
um,
excuse me,
when you,
when you talk to people about mental
performance,
have there been studies that have shown
any variation between,
uh,
the same individuals on a Ketogenic Diet
or carbohydrate,
glucose based diet in terms of mental
function?
Not good studies and not really good.
So what Ha has been done?
Uh,
I mean the first study I would say
purely key to genic study that I'm aware
of.
Use something as simple as medium chain
triglycerides.
And uh,
it was actually a substance that the
chemical name was ace 12.
Oh,
two.
And that substance is in the patent list
as a substance called AC 12.
Oh,
two for people unfamiliar with mct oil,
coconut oil.
Yeah.
So if you were to pull this patent,
uh,
interestingly,
Mike,
my colleague and friend,
Dr Mary Newport did and wrote a book on
Alzheimer's disease about the use of,
of ketones for Alzheimer's.
Uh,
she identified that the ingredients in
this supplement that helped to enhance
cognitive function in people with mild
cognitive impairment.
The,
the ingredient of this,
if you dig into the patent,
was caprylic triglyceride,
which is a medium chain triglyceride,
mct oil.
And they did a study.
It was a double blind controlled study
that showed that people who
interestingly they were not apo e four
positive,
that group did not respond.
But,
uh,
which is another kind of pathway we can
go down,
but they,
their improvement in cognitive function
correlated with their elevation and
ketone levels with this supplement.
It was a fat that when you consume it
independent and the amount of
carbohydrates you consume,
it converts that fat into Beta
hydroxybutyrate,
which you can measure with a little
blood meter and adds that level creeped
up and it didn't even have to creep up
that high.
It was like point six that they were
getting significant improvements in the
mini mental status test and other tests
that are sort of like the standard test
for Alzheimer's disease.
And that really got me interested
because I knew that levels could go up
way higher than point zero six and
they're showing that there's a
correlation as ketone levels rise up,
uh,
that you have a proportional increase in
cognitive function.
So I'm thinking with a ketone ester or
other types of Ketones,
you could elevate that to one,
two,
three and four millimolar and then get
some really robust because that's
sending a lot of energy to the brain.
So every millimolar of Beta
hydroxybutyrate that's in your blood
could it's been estimated that it gives
you,
like your brain,
about a 10 percent boost in energy.
It can restore energy up to up to 10
percent.
If you look at a,
if you do a,
an fdg pet scan and um,
and a ketone pet scan,
so you do a dual imaging for that.
Dr Steven Koonin in Canada has done
some,
some work on that,
but that's insane that it was so,
like for
college students or someone who's
studying for an exam or someone is about
to do something very important.
I'm exogenous.
Ketones should be like standard,
right?
Well,
uh,
yeah,
there's some pretty good evidence to
show,
but is that especially if you have a
deficit,
right.
So,
uh,
and actually,
you know,
the application that I'm using it for is
in an extreme environment when your
brain is already at a deficit.
Uh,
but we could say we're at a deficit,
right?
So tomorrow I'm jumping on a red eye and
I can't sleep on a plane and night land,
you know,
and go to my university where I have to
teach for a couple hours and then drive
a couple hours north and give another
lecture at night and I'll be on zero
sleep.
And I would not even attempt that if I
was,
you know,
wasn't doing what I have been doing.
Like I've kind of figured out protocols
where I can allow me to function even on
extreme lack of sleep.
So build the motor through it.
I'm sorry to interrupt,
but.
So when you land,
so what would you immediately take some
sort of an exotic as ketone,
some sort of what,
what do you take?
Like what are you,
ketone supplements?
That's
a lie.
There's a wide variety of ketone
supplements on the market.
So I'm kind of a food guy so I just used
them a almost kind of sparingly,
but I do tend to use them every day.
Uh,
the supplements that I've packed my bag
are.
The key genex supplement is one that I'm
a ben using and also the Pruvit Keto os
product that mixes Beta hydroxybutyrate
salt with mct powder.
So there's a couple other forms of just
Beta hydroxy butyrate,
but our studies show that just consuming
Beta hydroxy butyrate does not give you,
at least in the,
the ketone salt formula,
does not give you a lot of the benefits
that we see in some of the studies that
we're running and the Beta
hydroxybutyrate needs to be mixed with
medium chain triglyceride fat and that's
pretty important and I think that that
has a number of benefits.
The medium chain triglyceride delays
gastric absorption,
so,
uh,
it also further boost ketone levels
higher than you could get with ketone
salts alone.
So you get an elevation of ketone levels
that sustained for longer and that
probably that sustainment is due to kind
of delaying gastric absorption because
the fat kind of delays the release of
the ketones into the blood stream.
And it also,
it's stimulating your own ketone
production.
So you're taking a fat right?
And that's what happens when you
mobilize body fat.
You have a wide variety of enzymes that
convert that fat into ketones.
If you take a ketogenic fat,
the same thing is happening.
You're revving up that system in
addition to the exogenous ketones,
so the,
the pruvit product,
Quito as a key gen x and,
and there was a couple other companies
emerging on the market.
We have our own company,
a ketone technologies,
and we are partnering with government
agencies like Department of the fence,
Onr,
NASA to do research to fund research
with these institutes to really nail
down the optimal formula,
uh,
for antiseizure affects the optimal
formula for a motor function,
affects the optimal formula even for
strength.
And the one was strength will probably
involve,
you know,
adding amino acids,
adding creatine monohydrate.
So these will be formulas that will be
optimized.
So our company is working on that.
We don't have any products yet,
but if you sign up for the newsletter,
we,
we will update people on the newsletter.
And then when the products do come out
in emerge,
you know,
we'll kind of let people know.
So when you,
when you say you're a food guy,
are there any foods that you can eat
that will sardines,
sardines?
Yes.
It's,
I,
I travel with a,
this trip it was canned chicken and
sardines.
So there's a couple of wild planet makes
a good Ken and Tim Ferriss,
I kind of turned him onto it and uh,
it really exploded the company,
like kind of emailed me and thanked me,
you know,
they're really exploding.
So it's a small company.
They do wild wild planet sardines and
they're packed and olive oil and there
might be,
depending on what you buy,
like a little bit of lemon,
they might have a slice of lemon or
lightly lightly smoked or whatever,
but they are really,
really good.
And uh,
I mean I look forward to eating them.
Uh,
for me I'm kind of weird.
Like that is a treat for me.
Uh,
and that's,
you know,
I've taken a lot of different things and
experimented with a lot of different
things and simply just eating sardines.
Like it's like the perfect food and eggs
to are the perfect food.
You asked me like where I get my fat
from A.
I do get a lot from the olive oil that
are packed in this already.
And so I eat a lot of fatty fish,
lots of egg yolks.
I will make an egg yolk omelet and I'll
give the whites to my dog for protein,
you know,
cause they need a little bit more
protein,
so I'll make an egg yolk omelet and I
will cook it in butter and um,
you know,
maybe make some asparagus on the side,
like cooked in butter.
So I get a lot of fat from a macadamia
nuts,
a few nuts,
sardines,
fatty fish,
a lot of salmon and a lot of egg yolks
and fatty cuts of meat.
So we go to the butcher and particularly
pick out fatty cuts of meat.
And I'm olive oil,
coconut oil,
mct oil are all things that we have you.
Have you ever had issues with Sardines
and heavy metals?
No.
Um,
I think heavy metals are more of an
issue with larger predatory fish.
Like,
I mean,
I think swordfish would be kind of at
the top of the chain there.
Uh,
of course,
you know,
you're eating like a Maaco shark or
something like that and you're going to
be ingesting.
And if you do that on a daily base,
I wouldn't want.
If you're a pregnant woman,
you know,
I would stay away from big predatory
fish,
but one thing about sardines is that
they can be farmed in a sustainable way
and uh,
the,
the amount of heavy metals will be
typically proportional to the size of
the fish and whether it's predatory.
The reason why I'm asking this is I was
eating sardines like two cans a day for
a while and I got my blood work done and
there was like a very trace amount of
arsenic and my sister arsenic and the
doctor said,
what are you eating?
And he was going over to different
things.
I said,
I eat a lot of sardines.
Do you know where it came from?
Those out the sardines?
Yeah.
No,
I don't know,
just whatever was on the shelf.
I mean,
we travel all over,
we're in Borneo and uh,
you know,
Malaysia and Indonesia and all these
places and you see some,
some boats coming in and those sardines
are going to various plants.
So,
and even bigger companies,
you know,
we'll source out wherever,
wherever is cheapest.
Uh,
so I like to be pretty particular about,
especially if I'm going to eat something
in such a high volume like where it's
coming from to actually visit the plant
and where it's coming in and get some
information to where it's coming from.
A,
you know,
we,
I do use some of the meats from the
butcher box,
so butcher box offers a wide array of,
of meat from grass fed animals and,
and that's,
uh,
a lot of our meals at nighttime are,
from,
from butcher box.
Uh,
but that's interesting about the
arsenic,
you know,
arsenic can,
uh,
get concentrated in the ground where
plants are grown in.
So,
uh,
if,
if rice is grown in,
in China or whatever plant is grown in
China and that,
that soil has arsenic in it.
Uh,
I lived behind our house,
we had like a peach orchard and apple
orchards are notorious for this,
for having high levels of arsenic just
based on the chemicals that were used
over time.
And uh,
so this is something to consider.
Maybe it's something you were eating
with the sardines or maybe it was a
sardines itself,
depending on what's already into
reading.
Have the nutritionist was pretty
convinced that with sardines,
want to cut them out in one way?
Yeah,
he was saying that it was probably just
from pollution.
Yeah,
it could be.
Yeah.
I mean that's why it's really important
to pick out,
you know,
where your food's coming from.
This company you recommend wild planet.
They're fantastic coming is doing the
farm in this audience.
Uh,
yeah,
they have.
There's different methods that you can
use that uh,
would kind of put you in the category of
sustainable farming for sardines.
So it's one of the few fishes that are
really low on the spectrum of,
of having heavy metals and things.
So if you're,
you know,
there's women.
I get this question a lot like,
you know,
if a woman becomes pregnant,
should they stop eating fish?
Who did they stop eating,
you know,
a Ahi tuna,
swordfish and things I would say.
Yeah,
definitely the big predatory fish you'd
probably want to cut back on.
Um,
I did take a couple courses in
neurotoxicology where we went over,
like mercury poisoning and,
and every possible chemical and,
and just the take home message was a for
the normal person,
probably not an issue.
Um,
you know,
unless you're consuming really high
levels.
In,
in Grad school I was eating these big
cans like 12,
I think there are 12 ounce cans of tuna
fish and there was like five servings
per can and I would eat like three cans
a day.
Like I would take that and add,
I was fat phobic at the time that it
would be a chunk light tuna now to put
balsamic vinegar on it.
And I would literally eat three of these
12 ounce cans a day and that would be 15
servings of tune per day.
And I did that day in and day out.
And uh,
no ill effects.
Uh,
well I never got tested at the time.
So nowadays I tend to do a lot of blood
work just to check different things.
Uh,
but no overt signs of toxicity or
anything.
Uh,
maybe like a little someone,
one of the professors that I was doing
something for,
she had or her friend had lost a lot of
hair due to eating tuna that had high
mercury and at the time like Kinda had a
lot of hair loss at the time,
but it was also kind of a stressful
period.
So maybe when I stopped eating I noticed
like,
this is back in my mid twenties now.
I haven't had a significant amount of
air loss since,
since,
uh,
and a couple people,
you know,
and that actually that's one of the
symptoms to have mercury toxicity.
We are tingling and feelings like kind
of neurological effects.
So just something,
something that you consider a,
but getting tested is probably a good
thing to do.
I've heard that from people that just
consumed ridiculous amounts of Sushi.
Yeah.
But I would,
I would imagine like Sushi or dealing
with smaller portions of the actual fish
itself,
it might be,
if you do that day in and day out,
it's probably good to get tested and
sometimes may not show up in the blood
in the serum.
You might have to look at the red blood
cell because sometimes you know,
some of these metals are more reflective
of the levels on the,
on the red blood cells or the hair too.
So there's different ways that you can.
You can measure it.
I read that you eat.
Was it candy oysters as well?
Yeah.
Yep.
It's something I usually bring it
thought.
I think I brought on this trip to like
candy oysters,
King Oscar.
There's a few brands out there that I
kind of vetted out things and oysters
are really rich and a lot of
micronutrients that could,
you could get depleted in,
on the Ketogenic Diet.
So B,
12 is something I do supplement
magnesium to be 12 insulation from
Ketogenic Diet.
What would that come from?
Well,
you know,
it could be due to a sources of b 12
that you're kind of eliminating through
food choices on the ketogenic diet.
A,
b,
12 was basically an animal based.
Uh,
yeah.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
And I've,
I've never met or I think I did measure
that once and it wasn't.
But people have reported to me that it
was the thing that showed up on my blood
work was lower on the low end of
magnesium and I was getting cramps at
the time and that's the only you asked
about side effects.
So the only side effect that I
experienced was cramps at nighttime,
always between three and four in the
morning and it would start in my foot
and then start to creep up to my cab
and,
or if I did like legs or something,
sometimes my hamstrings.
And then when I,
the magnesium supplementation a really
prevented much of that.
Have you ever used an isolation tank?
No.
One of the cool things about her is that
you get my museum to the water.
That's right.
Yeah.
Because the water's filled with a salt
and the salt is magnesium and I don't
know,
I think there's,
there's pretty legit a science behind
that.
I was a traveling in,
um,
in Israel and I went to the Dead Sea,
which is really high in magnesium and it
has a calming effect,
uh,
which is reportedly due to the very high
magnesium levels and other salts that
are in there.
So that magnesium is relatively small
molecular weight that anything with a
molecular weight like under three,
400,
I think can,
can get into your bloodstream.
Yeah,
I think that's why people like those
epsom salt baths.
I think that's one of the things that
relaxes people.
Yup.
Yeah.
And epsom salt bath is,
you're talking about a very small amount
of salt in comparison to a tank which
has my tank is a thousand pounds of
epsom salts in it and 11 inches water.
So because you're so buoyant,
you just need to do this daily at your
house.
No,
not daily,
but whenever I want,
because it's in my basement,
I just go down there and get into it,
but it's a,
the relaxing effects.
It's pretty profound.
That's interesting.
You know what it brings to mind?
Most of the.
I've had at least a half dozen emails
about doing epsom salt baths from als
patients because als is associated with
a chemical called glutamate,
which is excitatory amino acid
transporter and high magnesium levels
can kind of,
some of the cytotoxic effects of high
glutamate and they were there physically
patients that they get and twitching
muscle twitching that they get and they
found that,
you know,
dosing magnesium or these epson salt
baths,
you know,
higher and magnesium can calm them down
and,
and also maybe mitigate some of the
twitching that they had,
which is probably a reflection of a
glutamate induced neurotoxicity.
So the cells are dying,
they're releasing.
So maybe neuroprotective in that way.
And it definitely,
you know,
I know magnesium,
you can feel it.
Like if you take a legit source of
magnesium that's bioavailable,
like magnesium glycinate or,
or other forms of magnesium,
you can really feel kind of a calming
effect.
Has know it makes sense.
A lot of people take it before they go
to bed.
Yep.
Yeah.
But the,
uh,
the tank is,
it just wouldn't get out of there.
Your whole body just feels relaxed.
I mean,
I think part of is because the zero
gravity effect of floating,
you're floating like you're,
you're very buoyant,
right in this because the water,
very heavy rail,
like the,
the Dead Sea,
like only maybe a third of your body is
kind of floating in it,
right?
Or half of your body,
half your body essentially like your
ears are underwater where your faces
above water.
It's amazing.
You got to try it.
I'm a big proponent of it.
But,
um,
the,
als,
is there a benefit in the ketogenic diet
to,
for people they'll off?
Yeah,
that's another application.
Uh,
there's a guy Dr Pasinetti and I think
he's at a and Mount Sinai in New York.
Uh,
he's got a couple of studies on this
looking at caprylic triglyceride,
which is a medium chain fatty acid and
he also,
prior to,
that's a clinical trial I think is
ongoing now.
But prior to that he demonstrated in a
mouse model of,
uh,
of als,
which is the sod one gene,
93 a mouse model and it has a gene
defect that mimics the familial form of
als.
Which accounts for maybe about 10 at
most,
20 percent of als a pathologies.
And he found that a ketogenic diet,
a improved motor function and some
neurological scores.
It did not improve overall survival
though.
So we actually followed up on that study
with a therapy that we call the deanna
protocol therapy after Deanna to don't.
And uh,
her father,
uh,
Dr Vinson to don't observe that his
daughter responded remarkably well to,
if you supplements,
which was our Janine
Alpha-ketoglutarate,
uh,
and a Gabba and a coenzyme q 10.
A few things that we actually put into a
supplement.
And we reproduced the same study using
this gold standard mouse model.
And we looked at motor function,
we looked neurological score.
And then we looked at total longterm
survival too.
And we found that using medium chain
triglycerides,
which was a ketogenic fat with Arginine
alpha-ketoglutarate,
which is something that's in preworkout
formulas.
It's evasive dilator from the Argentine.
Uh,
we used a Gabba was in that or any view
if ventilated form of gamma that crosses
the blood brain barrier and um,
and coenzyme q 10 in the form of
identity known,
which was kind of like the drug like
form of it,
I think it's still available.
You can get it online,
it might be kind of a drug or Ubiquinol,
which is a powerful warm.
So those supplements together I think
offer are neuroprotective in a way and
it had a therapeutic and what I would
call performance enhancing effect on
this als mouse model.
And those supplements had a therapeutic
effect on Deanna to don't.
I mean there's other things in the
what's called the Deanna Protocol,
uh,
people interested in this can go to
winning the fight foundation.
Uh,
it's a Tampa based als,
a five zero,
one c three foundation and you can sign
up on the foundation and they give you
the actual protocol and there's more
than a thousand patients registered on
this that are benefiting from the end.
There's several peer reviewed studies on
this.
Uh,
ideally we'd like to get enough funding
to do a human study,
but the mouse works pretty compelling
and it just,
it's just,
it,
it's an extension of work that has
already been done really in further
supporting a compelling support for this
proof of concept for using a metabolic
based approach like targeting energy
metabolism,
preserving mitochondrial function.
So the cells work better.
No,
when you were talking about epileptic
kids and I'm supplementing their diet
with ketone supplements because a lot of
them have a hard time following
kidogenic diet.
Can you get the same benefits of a
ketogenic diet by following a standard
American diet and supplementing with
exogenous ketones?
I doubt it at this time with the ones
that are commercially available.
But I do think that was some of the
ketone esters in development right now.
We've observed using a range of
different animal models that,
uh,
the thing is that these things are not
very palatable.
Third,
pricey to make a,
but we're working with various companies
and doing what's required for the FDA to
be generally recognized as safe or some
of these compounds.
I don't think they taste bad.
I've heard people complain about like
think eugenics.
I didn't think it was pro bono.
Ingenix actually tastes pretty good.
Uh,
don't let it sit.
If you mix it up.
That's one problem with the eugenics.
If you mix it up and let it sit,
then it's like,
tastes like battery acid for were
allowed.
But so I mix it up and if you just keep
it with some ice cubes in it,
you can probably keep it around for
about a half hour.
But I generally try to drink it pretty
quick.
But some of them,
some of them are nasty.
Yeah.
Uh,
well the ketone esters.
So these are things that if I gave you
right now you would gag.
You would not be able to drink it.
Somebody sent me some.
Where's that jazz?
We still have that laying around here,
that little thing to ketone esters and
some dude sent.
It was in like a sealed,
a little foil seal plastic thing.
I'd be curious.
I know all the,
all the people behind this was here
somewhere.
Okay.
This place is a mess.
What else?
Um,
so like if someone had a big bowl of
pasta and then they took something like
key genics,
would that knock you back in the state
of Ketosis?
Yeah,
you could,
you could eat a bowl of pasta and then
consumer key gen x product and then test
your test your blood ketones.
I didn't.
Would it look like you're on a strict
ketogenic diet that's a mild,
like a,
what I would call a modified atkins diet
were as to the ketone ester.
You could eat a bowl of pasta and then
take a ketone ester and it would look
like you fasted for 10 days.
So it puts you into starvation level
ketosis.
So interestingly,
another application of ketones is that
it lowers blood glucose and we don't
know why we're studying that right now.
But uh,
and it may do it by your liver is like
the main regulator of what your glucose
is.
So your liver as glycogen in it,
and it's constantly being broken down
and kind of spilling glucose into a.
It may be affecting that process or it
may be enhancing insulin sensitivity,
which means you take ketones and your
cells use the glucose that there becomes
more readily available to the cells
which greater uptake.
So we're looking into precisely why when
you consume exogenous Ketones,
why glucose goes down,
we've replicated it many times,
different forms of ketones.
So would that be a way for a person who
maybe he's just not so good at being
disciplined with their diet to just
throw it in there like say God,
I want him to have some ice cream,
but I've been really good with my diet.
Fuck it.
I'll just have the ice cream within.
Have some key x or something like that
afterwards.
Well,
I firmly believe there's no shortcuts
and I think of ketones and I try to.
I think I mentioned this on Tim Ferriss
too,
and he put it in there that ketones are
just another source of energy.
So if you have,
if you're eating 2000 calories of food
and then taken lots of ketone
supplements,
you are eating a lot more than 2000
calories of food
[inaudible] can you tell as fat,
but as far as like gaining weight,
but as far as like keeping your body
into a state of Ketosis,
it actually does work.
Absolutely,
and the benefits of that would be a
maybe not weight loss,
but by elevating your blood ketone
levels,
there's a lot of beneficial effects.
Even from a signaling standpoint,
like completely independent of
metabolism.
We know that it's a a,
a super fuel essentially for the brain
that you can.
Your brain cells can generate energy
from,
from ketones in a more efficient manner
than than glucose.
That's really hard for people to believe
because that's the one thing that people
always would say,
you need glucose to fuel your brain
under certain conditions.
So there are a few stipulations to that
and I could get a little bit technical,
but for example,
I mean obviously if you have one
deficiency syndrome,
you know you are.
You're transporting it,
but they're.
Your brain has a number of things that
prevent it from using glucose
effectively,
so in many cases ketones would be the
preferred source of fuel.
For example,
there may be like with Alzheimer's
disease or maybe if you even if you have
a traumatic brain injury,
there is an internalization of the glut
three transporter so that you have cells
right and glucose was trying to get in,
but the glut three transporter isn't on
the membrane or you can have a a
dysregulation or an inhibition of
[inaudible] hydrogenate complex PDH
complex,
and that enzyme is really the
gatekeeper.
It's almost like the.
It's the governor.
It's a throttle that lets the glucose
into the cell to create the feed into
what we call anaplerotic pathway is to
drive the TCA cycle,
the krebs cycle,
and that makes reduced intermediate that
drive the electron transport chain to
make ATP so that it's like a gatekeeper
and ketones completely bypass that
process.
So if you have no glove,
three,
if you have impaired activity of PDH
complex,
which a lot of people who are,
you know,
carbohydrate components say,
well,
you're inhibiting the PDH complex.
If you're on occasion,
thank diet and I don't think there's
evidence of that,
but the key tones essentially bypass
those steps and can restore and preserve
brain energy metabolism even if those
things are dysregulated or dysfunctional
in a number of pathologies,
you know,
make them dysfunctional.
Uh,
and this is a general state of aging.
It's thought that as we age,
we have a proportional decrease in,
um,
in glucose energy metabolism in the
brain,
but that's not the case with ketones.
So as we age,
the data that has been collected so far
shows that we have essentially the same
ketone energy metabolism as from young
to adults.
Wow.
So that's major implicated.
You can graph it out and you know,
we've had speakers at our conference
that did that and you can see kind of
like a plateauing effect and a decrease
in brain energy,
uh,
consumption from glucose.
Whereas with the ketones a,
it bypasses many of the rate limiting
steps that are associated with impaired
glucose metabolism in the brain.
It's almost hard to believe when you
rattle off the laundry list of benefits
of the Ketogenic Diet,
you know,
for a lot of people they're like,
well,
how is this?
It seems crazy.
It seems like it.
It will.
If it seems like everyone should be on
it.
And it seems crazy that so many benefits
are attributable to this fat based fat
burning diet.
There's a lot of bands I don't,
you know,
like my wife does not eat damage.
It's a relatively high carbohydrate diet
with people enjoy it.
That's because she enjoys it and that's
because her carbohydrate tolerance is
really remarkably high and some people
do really well on high carbs and you say
until you're testing her.
Uh,
yeah,
like,
well I've tested her blood and are
ketones to and she can get rapidly into
a state of ketosis.
I mean,
we're testing some products now for
ketone technologies or our company and
uh,
various products.
And she can.
It's the first time I've actually seen
her ketones levels up where mine are and
sustain it over a period of time.
And she's like,
this is awesome.
This is just from taking a product a for
taking himself,
just the formulation of specific
products,
uh,
and uh,
so there are a lot of benefits,
but it's just,
I think of it as like one tool in a
toolbox,
you know,
simple carbohydrate restriction,
like it doesn't have to be acutely drank
diet,
but simply restricting your
carbohydrates is a powerful hammer.
For example,
for type two diabetes and a Virta health
is doing more for the medical management
of type two diabetes than any other
entity that I know of.
I mean,
I think their goal is in the next decade
to reverse a $100 million cases of type
two diabetes.
Like our government spends way more a
like $200,000,000,000
of funding for managing diabetes.
Uh,
and you know,
NASA's budget is something like a $19
billion per year or something like that.
So it compare that and the,
uh,
you know,
we know that type two diabetes,
for example,
which is an obesity,
the major problem for type two diabetes
is carbohydrate intolerance.
So why would you,
why would a registered dietitian
administer a carbohydrate based diet to
a type two diabetes person who has a
problem with carbohydrate intolerance
because,
and that's reflected in their elevated
hemoglobin h,
one C or glucose levels or insulin
levels.
Uh,
so the Virta is created a platform of
people who using an APP will allow you
to,
uh,
to follow,
adhere to carbohydrate restriction and
acute agentic diet to essentially not
just manage it but just like completely
reverse it.
And I would,
I think the numbers are something like
89,
almost 90 percent of people from the
data they collected so far and publish
almost 90 percent of people might be 89
or 87 percent can either completely get
off insulin or like reduce it down to
very low levels just simply by using a
carbohydrate restricted diet.
And that has,
that's profound.
I mean imagine the number of people that
can get off medication,
you know,
what that can do to the healthcare
system,
the healthcare burden of paying all
these dollars for drug management of
type two diabetes,
which is going up to epidemic
proportions.
So yeah,
so,
so people are out there and they have
type two diabetes,
just go to Virta health and you'll see
an amazing array of clinicians,
basic scientists and registered
Dietitians that assist people for the
medical management of type two diabetes.
It's just stunning.
The list is.
Oh,
it was good.
Like the low hanging fruit is definitely
type two diabetes,
so I'm glad to see the field go into
that direction.
But for many,
many years,
many decades,
the only application when I got into
this research,
the only application with pediatric
epilepsy and then two years after that
it was like it works for adult epilepsy.
So it's taken so much time for the
science to prove kind of what we already
knew.
Right.
That therapeutic ketosis was supplying
ketones to the brain.
That's an alternative form of energy and
obviously that has more implications
than just helping your brain for
epilepsy.
And there's so many other applications,
you know,
when you're uncovering all this and when
you're doing all this research and
studying it and you're finding all these
benefits,
have you tried to figure out or
contemplate like what is the cause,
like why is it so beneficial for your
body to live off fats versus your body
to live off glucose?
Is this something that we evolved to
live off fats?
Is this like,
is it a better primary source?
Is it something that our body can exist
off of glucose but really were designed
to live off fat.
It's like,
what is the cause?
Oh,
it's multi.
I mean there's many answers to that
question,
but I'll tell you kind of what I think
that many people do really well on a
carbohydrate based with no overt signs
of,
you know,
pathology,
especially really active people in that
class.
Like I always kind of joke,
like the people that are most interested
in the ketogenic diets are.
Many of them are athletes that contact
me.
Uh,
but a lot of people have health problems
too.
Uh,
but the.
But the athletes are typically not the
ones who necessarily need it,
but they can benefit of it.
I mean,
a lot of,
you know,
if there's football players out there
and people that are predisposed to
concussion or brain injury,
I think it's really good to be on a key
to genic diet.
That's Kinda like a whole nother area we
can go into
now for athletes when you're talking
about people that like maybe they don't
need it for weight loss or they don't
need it for a lot of it.
Is it because the massive amount of
calories,
the calories that they're burning and
their nutritional requirements almost
mitigates the negative effect of having
a glucose based diet.
Yeah,
it really does come down to calorie
control.
So if you have a surplus amount of
calories coming in,
you know,
even with an athlete,
you're gonna start to get some over
metabolic effects and negative,
you know,
biomarkers kind of showing up.
And if you do that chronically,
it'll ultimately lead to chronic
inflammation.
Maybe some,
you know,
brain fog and other things.
Uh,
W,
what I have observed is that,
you know,
I mean you're asking like a why was your
question,
like why aren't people not following
this or what's the benefit
question was like because you're
studying this so deeply,
like have you ever contemplated like
what is the root cause?
Like why are we so good at burning fats?
Why is it so beneficial?
There's so many health benefits and it
seems like there's so many negative
consequences of,
of having a high carbohydrate diet,
especially for sedentary individual.
Yeah.
I think you really,
to put this into context,
you have to think the negative effects
from high carbohydrate diet are due to a
calorie surplus.
So I think a carbohydrate based diet
could work fantastic for a lot of people
who count their macros,
who manage their calories,
but people are horrible predictors or
estimators of how many grams of
carbohydrates,
you know,
they walked into the kitchen and grabbed
some grapes,
they grab a chocolate,
they don't.
So that's why it's really good if they
want to get a handle on this to optimize
or total health and performance and
things to really have an app where they
can calculate their macros and uneasy,
you know,
to do format like avatar nutrition does.
Uh,
so that's.
So I think when you are bolusing glucose
or bolusing carbohydrates,
a couple meals a day,
you have that scenario that I talked
about.
You have a spike in glucose and a
release of insulin and for many people,
which I had was,
is Postprandial dip in blood glucose
where you'd go hypoglycemic after two or
three hours and that would have me
searching for food again.
I would get irritable,
I would get sleepy,
my performance would drop when you go
on.
Didn't even have to be like a ketogenic
diet.
Just low carb can completely in many
cases if not abolished,
significantly attenuate that rise in
glucose and that release and insulin.
Uh,
and,
and you know,
with a carbohydrate based Diet you can
throw in more fat and fiber and buffer
that too.
But a purely ketogenic diet is kind of
non glycaemic.
Like,
you don't have any rise in that.
And the practical effects of that is
that it tends to allow the person to
control their appetite and so they're
kind of controlling them and appetite
suppression and just kind of.
And that's how it's thought that the
Ketogenic Diet works too,
is that you don't have these spikes in
glucose and hormones and things like
that that could set off a seizure,
is that,
uh,
the leading scientists in this field a
really believed that it helps put the
brain into a state of homeostasis better
and if there's less kind of energy
spikes and less kind of noise in the
system,
uh,
from a physiological standpoint that the
brains,
uh,
the brain's energy system and the,
the,
the neuropharmacology of the brain
itself,
the neurotransmitters,
the balance of Gaba to glutamate and
Gaba and Serotonin and other things will
be balanced in a way that would make
seizures much less likely to occur.
So,
and I think that's what it does from a,
from a,
uh,
feeding behavior from a neuroendocrine
point of view,
is that it helps to,
when you have all these hormones and,
and,
uh,
metabolites,
you know,
going all over in the blood,
the ketogenic diet keeps it into a range
where there's a lot less noise in the
system and you can see this,
uh,
by a patient,
a type one diabetes patient,
for example,
who goes from eating a high carbohydrate
diet to a key to genic diet where their
Dexcom continuous glucose measurement is
all over the place.
If you look at,
you know,
several days of data and if they
transitioned to a ketogenic diet,
I mean the highest,
there's way few highs and a few lows and
it's within a tight range.
And there they stay within the range
where they're optimized,
I would say.
So they're in a glucose range where
they're optimized and that's what
happens.
That's,
you know,
that happens obviously with a type one
diabetic who's trying to chase the
glucose with insulin.
But for the average person,
the same thing happens.
And that's why a lot of people feel
better,
they have less cravings and there were
more likely to adhere and stick to their
diet and not kind of fall off the wagon
and kind of overeat and you have surplus
calories.
So,
so high carbohydrate diet is completely
manageable and people who knew how to
manage their calories,
but that's really hard for most people
will do.
So I think the APP based programs that
are coming out are really,
really handy in there.
Uh,
I think there'll be kind of the wave of
the future for people who want to
optimize their,
their body composition and their
performance,
and to have a kito option of that too,
where you can tighten,
titrate and optimize your Keto Diet.
And then there was an ai system that
tells you how to improve those ratios
over time to hit your goals.
I think that's really the future.
The cravings,
uh,
that,
that's a huge factor.
The not just the energy crash,
but also the lack of hunger.
It's a,
it's really weird.
Like I always felt like if you didn't
eat for a few hours,
you just started getting,
God,
I got to eat and you have this weird
feeling,
but that weird feeling is entirely
connected to glucose when you're on a
fat based fat burning diet.
That the,
even knowing that you're hungry is a
different knowing.
It's like it's in the other room.
Yeah.
It's not like it's like next to you
sitting on your shoulder yelling in your
ear.
Come on man,
let's eat.
You know,
there's a frantic feeling that a lot of
people get.
I've seen my wife,
I've seen it when she's hungry.
We gotta stop.
We gotta pull over when she needs ice
cream.
I mean it's,
it's,
I just,
you know,
give in and say,
okay,
we're gonna we're gonna.
Pull over.
Uh,
and I remember feeling that way too when
I would kind of go off the wagon and
need a half of a box of toll house
cookies.
Uh,
but yesterday I three packets of
something called Quito cookies and uh,
I put some in your,
your little gift bag there.
Um,
yeah,
and these Quito cookie.
So I just,
I had never eaten three packets
together,
so I was curious.
Uh,
let me,
Oh,
that's energy bits.
So energy bits is I think a fantastic
Selena.
So spirit,
Spirulina has an enormous amount of
research behind it and uh,
it's one of the products I used on the
NASA neemo mission because we didn't
really have access to fresh vegetables
or fighter nutrients down there.
So snickerdoodle Huh?
At the snickerdoodle bar.
And then there was a chocolate chip bar
and a fudge fudge chip bar where could
just go to Quito,
cookie.com.
And so they are,
that's like my Quito comfort food.
So when I travel with that,
I might have another box out there for
you.
So you have chocolate chip snicker
doodle.
Yeah,
fledged chip.
Uh,
so you can eat that typically when,
if I like a toll house chocolate chip
cookie,
I would have that crash that we were
talking about and now it'd be ravenous,
you know,
after a.
There you go.
Uh,
so no sugar.
So it's completely like low-glycemic for
me.
They're like non glycaemic.
Uh,
so I measured my,
My,
uh,
glucose after eating three packets of
them because I went to,
yeah,
there was the guys behind it.
So I actually just saw them at the low
carb,
a USA conference where a number of
speakers there were on the show.
Gary Taubes with their robb wolf was
there.
I didn't get to speak to them,
uh,
because it was just so busy.
But Quito cookie is one of those food
that's evolving out of this,
you know,
this kind of movement.
I would say that the key to genic diet
diet is becoming a lifestyle.
So not something that's used for
pediatric epilepsy,
but something like the average person
can follow to just feel better.
And for me,
I could eat a Keto meal in the morning
and I can hammer out 12 hours of work in
the lab and not even get any cravings to
eat at all.
And that,
for me,
that translated into more grants,
more publications,
more work done in the lab.
And I kind of attributed in some way
that,
you know,
my career has gotten a really big boost
because I'm more cognitively aware and
resilient even during periods of sleep
deprivation.
I can just work longer periods and I
kind of utilized Quito to my advantage
in that way.
Fascinating.
I really had no idea about exogenous
ketones,
improving mental function,
like taking them to actually really like
it would be a good idea to take them
before anything taxing.
I'm going to try and take a number for
podcasts and taking them before comedy
shows or UFC events and see if maybe my
brain fires better because I mean that's
just amazing.
Yeah.
Uh,
my,
my wife was actually a,
she spearheaded a program,
uh,
looking at absence seizures.
So a lot of people have seizures,
don't have like tonic clonic seizures,
but they'll just look and stare into
space and then wake up out of it with me
all the seizures champion.
I didn't even know he's a good man,
but I feel like an illusion and you just
got to try them,
try them.
Raj,
do you have a glucose ketone
measurement?
I did have that,
but I have a lot of calluses and I was
like,
I had a really stabbed the shit out of
my fingers.
Yeah,
you do.
I thought I had calluses.
I got,
I got pretty bad council.
But um,
yeah.
So,
uh,
what was I gonna say?
Oh,
so anxiety other than glucose meter,
the one that stabs you because it wasn't
really working that well,
not really.
I mean they go in the side of your hand.
I'm like,
fuck,
fuck man.
Yeah.
So we'd go to the fingertips.
I just take an actual syringe like a
needle and just plug it in or I have.
Yeah.
So I just,
I don't really feel that I've done it so
many times,
but uh,
but yeah,
taking exogenous ketones can help.
We publish a paper and frontiers.
It reduced anxiety behavior about 25 to
30 percent in our rats.
So they would go out into what's called
an elevated plus maze into the open arm
where they're like on a catwalk and they
could fall off or be exposed environment
typically produce a fear response or
they could run back into the little
cave.
And the Beta hydroxybutyrate salt plus
the medium chain triglyceride
combination,
actually reduce that fear behavior.
Uh,
maybe it would be.
I mean,
I'm sure you're completely comfortable
being out on front of the stage,
uh,
but for people that have anxiety
problems,
which is a big part of people who have
stress,
it kind of exacerbates anxiety.
Uh,
I mean,
I felt it early on in my career.
I knew that being in a state of Ketosis
just makes me more mellow.
Well,
you know,
one thing that would help me with is,
um,
I bow hunt.
Yeah.
And bowhunting is behind.
Really.
My brother was a,
he was a big bow hunter.
He writes for Peterson.
But when a magazine and I saw a tweet,
I saw a.
yeah,
we had that pro force extreme,
I think bose.
Yeah.
I grew up in a,
in a boat.
I grew up in a hunting family.
So I quickly noticed some of the stuff
out in here.
So,
um,
that's probably one of the most
stressful things I do.
Like people think that like doing
standup,
a stressful or live podcast or
broadcast,
those are nothing compared to
bowhunting.
Drawing back on a live animal and your
heart starts racing,
start adrenaline rush,
you have target panic where you can't
remember what you're doing and you go
into autopilot and there's all sorts of
methods to mitigate that by forcing your
brain into a closed loop system instead
of an open loop system,
repeating mantras,
going over different facets of your shot
process.
But maybe I'm ketones and being in an
acute agentic state,
especially exoticness ketones before you
hunt,
would mitigate some of those issues.
Definitely help.
I mean,
I think you've had them on the podcast,
Wim Hoff method.
I'm sure something I'm getting into a
was talking with a quest ceo last night,
uh,
about Butenko,
guy in Russia designed some,
some system that allows you.
It's a,
it's a program of breathing.
I have the APP on my phone.
I haven't,
I haven't used it yet,
but it allows you to increase your CEO
to threshold.
So the drive to breathe actually does
not come from a lack of oxygen.
It,
uh,
through CEO to chemo receptors on the
ventral surface of your Medulla,
in,
in your brainstem,
that senscio too,
and when they sent ceo to that,
that's your urge to breathe.
That's your drive.
And then you have a backup,
a sort of like a redundant mechanism,
the carotid body that the bifurcation,
the common carotid artery right here
will since oxygen and it's kind of like
more of a fail safe that's,
I studied these things,
you know,
for my phd and these neurons like Kelly
sense how they sense things,
but so you can increase your CEO to
threshold over time using various
breathing protocols and that can create
an enormous effect on kind of reducing
anxiety in these situations where a big
buck comes up and you're drawing back on
it,
or in general,
just the level oxygenation that you
have.
So retaining some co two,
if you do it through training,
can actually enhance the vasodilation
effect and can maybe reverse even in
hyperoxygenate systems in your body.
So that's the theory.
And there's some,
there's quite a few studies behind it.
I really have to delve into the studies.
But uh,
the Wim Hoff method is one method.
I've been fascinated with him.
I really want to meet him.
Actually.
I love that I would go,
I want to bring him to the lab and
actually do some research on him.
Okay.
Connect your guide will be awesome.
Yeah.
These cookies or like a mirage,
it's like you hold them,
they have weight cookie.
You bite into them,
you'll like,
this is going to be like eating a cookie
and then you chewing it and it's almost
like it vanishes like fairy dust in
front of your eyes.
But it's good though.
It's really good.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not saying it's a mirage,
like their bullshit.
I'm saying like I'm there.
It's a very strange texture to them.
Yeah.
Because obviously there's no grain it
and there's something about eating and
maturing them where your body goes,
hey,
uh,
what'd you fucking lie to us?
Hooky Bro.
Like it tastes good,
but there's something about chewing it
and eating it.
It's like,
Eh,
it vanish.
It's pretty substantial to the
significant amount of fat in it.
Uh,
so I was a little.
Yeah,
I was a little skeptical when they came,
I was like,
okay,
because people send me so many products
and I vet out what actually impacts,
you know,
my blood glucose and ketone levels and
then maybe about 10 percent of the
products that people send me.
I really liked like the energy bits
here,
the spirulina tablets,
I can take massive amounts and actually
get a significant amount of protein and
there's absolutely no glycemic effect
and I'm getting huge amounts of
phytonutrients in it.
So I brought that on these little snack.
I down like 30 at a time.
So it's 33 servings a thousand tablets.
Jesus.
Yeah.
So that would be like a month supply and
you know,
you can chew them,
they taste kind of grassy and there's a
little blip in there.
Yeah.
Or if you don't shoot them,
if you just swallow them,
you don't taste them.
If they don't.
There's about.
And that's what I did taste like.
I'm almost like sesame seeds.
Yeah.
I like,
I like it,
I like it actually.
Sunflower seeds don't sort of tastes
like the lady Catherine.
She was on a shark tank and actually
they kind of slammed her because I think
she evaluated the company high or they
didn't like the taste.
That was the main reason that,
that they didn't like it,
so I mean guys like you and me and most
guys would be totally fine with the
taste and the amount of nutrition that's
in that and the density of that makes it
an awesome food for things like special
ops guys or even even NASA.
I mean there's a lot of nutrition in
that little bag right there.
So stunning to me.
How much like mouth,
pleasure factors into people's lives?
Absolutely.
Don't like the taste.
Well,
something can be fantastic for you.
Like,
like I expect that out of my seven year
old,
you know,
she's like,
Eh,
taste gross.
I don't like it.
I'm like,
I get it.
Yeah.
We'll get out of a 37 year old Jesus
Christ.
Ninety percent of people really eat.
It's a pleasurable thing to them and
they don't want to restrict that in any
way,
shape or form.
That's crazy to me because you don't
have to restrict it just for the most
part taken healthy nutrients and you're
like this,
like,
this is not bad like Jesus Christ,
if this is the most suffering you get in
a day,
talk about first world problems,
you know,
these little energy bits.
There weren't the best thing I've ever
had.
I don't know what I'm going to do now.
That's not bad.
I mean I see it from the general
consumer point of view,
like I could see maybe,
but once they know the science behind
it,
like the CEO sent me a stack of research
papers and are all off of pub med and I
started looking through them and then
double checking on pub med and realizing
there's a lot of science behind this.
And actually NASA was interested in
algae and making capsules because it's a
super,
it's super high in protein has all these
phytonutrients and uh,
you can grow it,
you could figure out a way to grow it in
space and stuff.
Uh,
so I think really that's a future.
Like things like Quito cookie will be a
gateway for people to say,
okay,
maybe I can go on this diet and I can
have these chocolate chip cookies here
too.
But then eventually your palette changes
over time and you don't crave those
foods anymore.
Like it never happened to me.
Now it's gotten close.
But man,
I smell some fresh bread or a bowl of
pasta,
like linguine with clams.
I'm in man.
But you can maybe control yourself a
little bit better.
Yeah,
you still crave it?
I don't actually crave that at all.
I'm going to crave sweets and chocolate
maybe.
Sometimes.
Not,
not so much.
I was a big ice cream guy though.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
He was eating some on his instagram.
So,
uh,
the institute that I'm associated with,
the Institute for Human and machine
cognition,
Ihmc it's run by the directors.
Ken Ford,
he was a former director,
uh,
in NASA executive and NASA and they have
a James Beard award winning chef that
they hired into Ihmc and he has a
specific,
a Keto ice cream recipe which is using
the mct and like a pinch of Stevia.
And when you eat the ice cream,
I mean,
it just blows your mind that this is ice
cream that you could eat every day,
a big bowl and stay on a ketogenic diet.
So these kinds of editing,
I feel innovative.
You're reading?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
It's really legit.
Like my wife,
my wife,
she's really like the litmus test.
So when I get products I give,
uh,
the last product I got was the Quito
Brownie,
so if you like Google,
Quito,
Brownie,
it'll,
it'll come up and,
you know,
I gave it to my wife and she was like,
yeah,
this is pretty good.
But it had like a,
a shell in it,
which kind of got caught on her teeth or
whatever.
And she loved the taste but it was a
little bit,
uh,
I think because she's so picky,
it was like,
oh,
I liked it but just had a shell on it or
whatever.
But Quito Brownie is like another food
and I see all these entrepreneurial guys
kind of emerging on the scene and being
very innovative in the way.
I mean,
it takes a long time to develop and test
a product that you can eat that's low
carb for one thing,
and then you could,
allows you to adhere,
to accuse yanked diet.
Have you had a cave shake?
You know,
those are,
I've heard about it.
Is that company got a bunch of the
fruit.
Oh,
maybe I can try one.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Okay.
I'll give you one right now if you want
one,
but uh,
we'll wait till after the show.
Oh yeah,
I'm forgotten those,
those are giant they're made with um,
a lot of good stuff in there.
But I think a lot of his coconut coconut
milk.
Yeah.
Um,
this Keto ice cream company,
was it called again?
Yeah.
Actually there's not a company that I
know of yet.
It's just,
uh,
I told them they needed to create some
ip around this,
this formula.
But uh,
it was uh,
the,
the Institute for Human and machine
cognition that the chef there picked it
up himself.
Yeah.
He has a number of recipes because,
uh,
the CEO there can forward.
I mean,
he's a huge fan of the shank diet and
it's how I got hooked up with him
because he realizes that it enhances his
cognition and performance and has
actually been a big help in moving
things into government agencies and
helping them acknowledge that this is a
very viable,
a form of a way to fuel the astronaut or
fueled a special ops guy.
So He's been kind of instrumental in
that regard.
And he is,
you know,
hired a,
a chef that cooks ketogenic and in a,
in a gourmet fashion,
a James Beard award winning chef,
which I didn't even know what that was
until I looked it up.
And I was like,
well,
these are very high level chefs that are
specifically in his expertise,
at least at the institute is to create
these key to genic recipes that are like
ultra gourmet and amazing to eat.
What about pasta?
Is there like an almond flour based
pasta?
And not that I've,
you know,
I've tried a lot of things,
but,
uh,
I would hesitate to recommend anything
just because I have not been impressed
enough to,
uh,
to really.
There's some protein pasta out there
that's a little bit low car,
but a lot of times they kind of fill you
up with a lot of soluble fiber and you
just become like a gas machine,
you know,
it might be good for your gut microbiome
in some ways,
but,
uh,
you're feeding all the bugs in there,
but,
uh,
for a large part like if you get,
you know,
every,
we have a certain threshold for soluble
fiber which gets broken down into
butyrate and other things in the gut.
Uh,
and if you exceed that,
you just become,
you know,
gas machine.
And so maybe it would be good in like a
small side dish.
Yeah.
So that's your weakness then pause.
So an ice cream too or.
No,
I mean I can go without ice cream and
sweets really don't get me that much.
I mean,
it's not that big of a deal.
It's not something that I massively
crave,
but I'm a big fan of Spaghetti.
Yeah,
it's a problem.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
uh,
I think that it's just one of those
things
where I bet if I just stopped taking it
for a long time,
stop eating it for a long time,
but that's been my cheap food for
awhile.
So if I just cut it out of my system
completely for like six months or
something like that,
I probably,
you know,
if you,
there's a book that has ice cream,
there's a recipe.
Jeff Bullock has a book,
it's called the art and science of low
carbohydrate performance and this will
appeal to your crowd because a lot of
mma guys I refer to the book and they
say this book was incredibly helpful to
me.
So the art and science of low
carbohydrate performance and there's a
arrest.
There may be a pasta recipe in the.
I know there's an ice cream recipe in
there that's not unlike the recipe I was
just talking about.
So.
But the pasta thing.
Yeah.
That would be.
If someone can nail that down,
that would be pretty good.
At logical achievement,
it would be filled with some weird stuff
that it.
You were just in Italy.
I saw some pictures where whereabouts
and did you have pasta and pizza when
you went off?
Like a rocket way off.
And I do that when I was in Naples,
I and I got to have pizza.
That was quite awhile ago.
But you know,
it's moderation too.
Well they also have different flower and
I talked to.
They do,
that's right.
Maynard maynard Keenan from the band
tool also has a,
an Osteria,
a restaurant and a um,
a vineyard that he runs in Arizona.
He's a weird guy,
but uh,
he explained on the podcast,
on the podcast rather than I did with
him recently.
The difference between the Pasta that we
have today in the bread we have today
and original heirloom wheat which is
less,
it's lower yield per acre and it has a
less complex gluten's in it.
And he's like,
that is what,
when people are talking about like the
difference between how your body
tolerates like certain gluten,
whether it's gluten sensitivity or not.
He's like just,
it's just a different feel.
And I really noticed that when I was in
Italy when I would eat their pasta.
I mean,
it just,
it tastes different,
it feels different when it's going down.
And I actually ordered a bunch of it
from,
from Italy,
and I even cooked it at home and I
noticed it
Lawrence.
And she.
Did you get any,
you don't have any gi?
So if I go,
which I don't,
if I go to the movies,
sometimes I'll get popcorn and I'm
completely okay.
Like eating popcorn and then,
you know,
a day or two later and back into ketosis
really fast without even exoticness
ketones.
But if I do eat pizza or pasta,
which I did in the beginning when I
would have like these cheat meals
occasionally,
uh,
I would have some major gi issues
because your body is,
you know,
digestion,
assimilation,
transport of these things.
You're typically eating on a day to day
and then you go without eating them and
it's like your body doesn't know what to
do with it.
But when I did go to Italy and we travel
around all over the place,
my wife,
you know,
loves to travel,
uh,
and we were in Naples and I ate maybe
two or three pieces of pizza.
I had absolutely no problems whereas
that in the US that would have bothered
me and maybe it was just a,
it may have been the flower on a
guarantee.
The flower,
it's a,
it's just a different kind of flour,
I think what they call it,
it's called double o flour.
See if you can find that jamie flower
that they use and they'll specify for
imported wheat flour from Italy that
it's a special type of flower and that
flower is essentially heirloom flour.
So the difference between like when you
buy a tomato from the grocery store and
it's Pale and bulletproof and you can
throw it down a flight of stairs and it
doesn't even get bruised versus heirloom
tomatoes,
which are almost like a fruit,
I mean really is essentially a fruit and
they're juicy and very delicate and
very,
very fragile as well.
There it is.
Is double o flour worth the price?
Well,
pull it up.
One that had the right.
Got It.
Um,
uh,
yeah.
I don't know man.
I mean that's my,
that's my big problem.
But if I,
if someone does do that,
if they save,
they follow a key to genic diet and they
eat a bowl of pasta,
I can't help it.
And then they take exogenous ketones and
it knocks them back into ketosis.
Is that,
will it stay that way even though they
bought the body to digest that pasta and
they'll be in ketosis again tomorrow?
Good question.
It won't.
It'll stay that way based upon the
Pharmaco kinetic properties of the
supplement you're consuming.
So a ketone salt product,
you know the ones that are on the
market.
If it's mixed with a fat,
like medium chain triglyceride,
a the Quito oms system and the eugenic
system,
our BHB and MCD,
you'll be sustained for longer.
But if you do choose to try to get the
benefits of ketones and you're on a
carbohydrate based diet,
you have to consume obviously more
exotic ones.
Ketones to get the benefits of ketones.
And you could do that though,
so someone could theoretically do that
and just take exogenous ketones and
maintain pretty much the
exact benefits.
And Yeah,
you can do that.
And a lot of people are kind of
confused,
or like,
well,
what's the body going to do with the
glucose?
Or what's the same thing?
You could say the same thing if you eat
fat,
you know,
what's the body going to do with the
glucose?
Well,
uh,
well interestingly,
glucose goes down and we don't actually
know why we think the liver kind of
sends out less and these products are
not really like a huge amount of
ketones,
right?
It's just enough to get you maybe into
the one millimolar range and we know
that's enough to give your brain like a
boost and give.
It's one millimolar of ketones in your
blood.
Actually,
record represents a pretty significant
source of energy that your brain can use
and that your heart can use.
We know the heart runs more efficiently
off ketones.
Uh,
and probably more importantly is that
the key tones function as signaling
molecules that inhibit anti inflammatory
processes.
Uh,
so deep dixit at Yale University did a
study actually with one of the captains.
What's his name?
His name is Deep Dixit Jesus Christ.
I never thought about it.
Yeah.
Now he's got a scientist at a comedian
right there.
I'm like,
wait,
hold up.
I always look at his Indian name,
but he always tells me to call him d,
But a deep Dick's,
Dick's,
it,
sorry.
He,
he's a really good scientists and the
leader in,
uh,
in studying the effects of calorie
restriction and a and ketones,
and he observed that ketones elevating
ketones has a signaling effect,
completely independent of the metabolic
effect,
which everybody thinks of ketones are a
source of energy,
but they are also like a hormone.
They're like a drug.
So they hit specific pathways.
The pathway that he found a at the study
at Yale was the NLRP three inflammasome.
You don't have to know that,
but uh,
when that Amazon is activated,
it releases a lot of inflammatory
cytokines in the body which are in that
inflamma.
Zoom is linked to a lot of age related
chronic diseases too.
So as we age,
we have more systemic chronic
inflammation.
So I always say the people that have
that can benefit most from the ketogenic
diet.
You tend to be get more insulin
resistant and more trunk obesity as we
age,
so they are people that will be a more
receptive to the benefits of the
Ketogenic Diet as we age,
we become more carbohydrate intolerant
as we age,
but anyway,
it's the Beta hydroxy butyrate is
functioning as an anti inflammatory,
like independent of the energy pathways.
So he established that and uh,
it was actually a diet that I helped him
formulate with exogenous ketones.
And after that got published a,
I got a number of emails from
pharmaceutical companies because they
wanted to sort of reverse engineer
something that had the same effect as a
key tone,
but to put it into a drug.
And that was a,
there,
there is a pretty intense,
you know,
interest in the signaling properties of
ketones and pharmaceutical companies,
especially histone deacetylase
inhibitors.
So Beta hydroxybutyrate ketone,
you measure it from your blood functions
to as what we call this h Jak inhibitor,
which affects the genes.
So you're actually turning on genes that
are neuro,
neuro,
protective,
that are cellular protective,
that are linked to longevity pathways.
So think about the rewards of developing
a drug that did the same thing,
but the financial reward,
you can't patent Beta hydroxybutyrate
and well in different forms maybe shows
you whenever something's good,
someone comes along and tries to fuck
with us.
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
you know,
you could say it's,
probably for the most part driven by
greed,
but there is a legitimate,
uh,
impact on human health and longevity.
Wouldn't that just be better suited for
the Diet?
Absolutely.
I think it's awesome that our body makes
this natural metabolite.
So the ketone salt products you buy on
the market are,
the ketones are derived from natural
sources.
So you are giving,
you know,
uh,
you are elevating a bio identical form
of a ketone that your body a,
there's a little bit of the debate
because there is a d form of Beta
hydroxy butyrate in the l form.
So we call that receive mic if they're
together,
they're receive make.
And The d form is kind of what your body
makes,
but it can also convert it to the l in
certain tissues and it can get really
complicated.
The important thing is that the salts
that you consume that are commercially
available,
the d form is more likely to be broken
down and utilized as a source of energy,
whereas the l form probably sticks
around more within the cell and we know
the l form actually also functions in
these signaling roles.
So the l form has antiinflammatory
effects,
the l form,
you know,
hit these signaling pathways.
So the received make mixtures that are
in the salts may have extra benefits
over just a pure deform because the l
form can kind of hang around and
stimulate all these pathways we know are
beneficial before it's get broken down
into fuel.
So there might be some sort of a benefit
for people even honest strict ketogenic
diet taking exogenous ketones.
Yes,
absolutely.
And I think,
you know,
we work really closely with uh,
the Charlie Foundation and I think the
kidogenic diet should never be replaced
with exogenous ketones at this point
because the science,
the research is not there yet to
validate it,
but we want to go in that direction
because there's some kids who really
like their fat intolerant.
They throw up when they like the
ketogenic diet because it's too high in
fat and a proportion of the kids are
like that.
Most kids can follow it.
But,
uh,
but even for like childhood cancers and
stuff,
we,
uh,
I,
I met with the,
the,
uh,
the Max love project.
Uh,
he was on Jimmy Kimmel Max.
He was a brain tumor,
a child with a brain tumor that is,
his family is treating them with a
ketogenic diet and they helped many
families around the area and they have a
foundation,
just Google Max love project and uh,
and his family is helping a Max adhere
to and stick to a key to genic diet as
an adjutant to his standard of care.
So not a replacement.
The huge drank diet does work remarkably
well for some people as maybe a
standalone therapy for cancer and have
the anticancer effects,
but as an adjunct to the standard of
care,
it's remarkably effective.
And they're working with,
um,
I think with Orange County yet.
So they have a lifestyle medicine
program at Children's hospital in Orange
County where they're helping a wide
variety of families who have kids with
cancer,
uh,
stick to and adhere to a key to genic
diet as part of a wellness program after
they went through their cancer
treatment.
Because if you're a child and you get
the standard chemotherapy,
you are kind of left in a situation
where you're far more likely to have a
lot of different health,
a negative health consequences after
that because the chemotherapy wipes out
your immune system and can create,
you know,
additional mutation.
So there's kind of like a fallout from
the,
from the standard of care and being on a
ketogenic diet can be cellular
protected,
can help you in a neoadjuvant and,
and after,
you know,
before standard of care and even after
Sandra care help you recover and get
your body back into like a detoxified
state if you want to use that term.
That's amazing.
Now how many cancer research places are
adopting this?
I mean,
it seems like a,
that would be gigantic and this is a big
shift over to standard care of just a
few few years ago.
Right?
Yeah.
So the idea is,
and we wrote a grant with the Moffitt
Cancer Institute,
which is a tea,
like a tier one cancer research center.
I mean,
they essentially reached out to us and
say there's,
there's significant interest in this
from the National Cancer Institute,
National,
uh,
Nih,
national institutes of health to use the
ketogenic diet as an adjective in at
this point instead of replacing standard
of care,
which,
uh,
only in situations where the standard of
care is not effective should that be the
case,
but as an event to further enhance the
efficacy of the standard care.
So the cues drank diet,
we know limits glucose,
a beat availability to the tumor which
requires a glucose for growth and
proliferation.
It decreases insulin,
adoptable bell and insulin signaling
drives cancer growth.
And it also elevates ketones.
And ketones may have an anticancer
effect.
And for the most part,
especially in very aggressive tumors
that have dysregulated Mitochondria,
they can't use the ketones for fuel a
nearly as well as they do like fuels
like a glucose and maybe even glutamine
amino acid.
So it enhances the standard of care and
helps them,
uh,
actually protects them from the healthy
cells,
from the radiation damage,
from the standard,
it sensitizes the tumor to radiation and
kills off more tumor.
And it protects your healthy cells.
So when my colleague Adrian check at the
Barrow Neurological Institute has done
some remarkable work in animal models
showing this and that has translated
into a human study and actually garnered
more interest in this area to use the
ketogenic diet as an edge event.
I think in some cases where the standard
of care has failed for Glioblastoma or
advanced metastatic cancer.
I think the key to genic diet can kind
of be a base therapy for a more
comprehensive metabolic based program.
And we wrote an article called the press
pulse where the key to genic diet and
maybe something like metformin and other
drugs can,
can be used to weaken in the cancer.
And unlimited fuel source and then you
can connect,
come in with more maybe more aggressive
ways like hyperbaric oxygen therapy,
which can reverse tumor hypoxia or
various a low dose chemo regimens so you
will weaken the cancer,
you know,
you put your body into a state of
Ketosis and then you come in and pulse
at predetermined time points maybe every
three weeks of therapy in a much lower
dosing regimen to gradually knocked down
and reduce the tumor volume over time
and you do it in a more gradual way
instead of going in there,
you know,
with surgery,
radiation and Chemo,
which is kind of like slash and burn and
it leaves the patient.
The patient coming out of that therapy
is much,
much weaker than when they came in.
So at therapy can be developed that when
the patient comes in and they come out
the other side,
they're actually in more robust health.
We know that they can,
you know,
we could do that doesn't grow.
That's possible from a theoretical
standpoint,
you know,
with various research being done in
animal models and what we know about
nutrition and physiology that can be
done.
It's just going to take some time to do
it.
It's just so interesting when you talk
about the shift of information.
I mean when you were in college,
being fat phobic,
you know,
to now being like one of the premier
guys that's out here preaching the
benefits of the key to genic die and
then seeing this,
I mean,
up until really recently,
cancer research always dependent upon
these,
you know,
chemotherapy and radiation and all these
different standards that everyone's been
having success with,
but the idea that you could actually
make a person healthier through the
Ketogenic Diet and hyperbaric chambers
and things along those lines.
That's a,
it's amazing.
Yeah.
Hyperbaric oxygen therapy actually is
FDA approved for things like radiation
necrosis.
Like when you have radiation,
you know,
on a tumor,
you have a lot of necrotic tissue and
patients would undergo hyperbaric oxygen
for radiation necrosis.
And,
you know,
I would,
I would go to these,
uh,
various conferences over the years and
talked to these physicians and these
patients would make remarkable
recoveries,
you know,
even after they have therapy.
And it seemed like something else was
going kind of going on here.
And,
uh,
and if I go back early in my work,
I mentioned that we develop these
technologies through our work with the
department of the fence and when the
officer where we,
we build a hyperbaric chamber and then
we buy an off the shelf microscope and
install it inside the chamber.
And then we close it up and then we
pressurize it to simulate,
you know,
what a dive would be while we're looking
at the Mitochondria and,
and even the cells.
And I did that with like Kelsey's stem
cells and neurons.
And we did it with a Glioblastoma cell
line and we noticed that the cells were
exploding with high levels of oxygen.
I didn't know what I was seeing at the
time,
but I looked into it more and started
contacting some of the leaders in the
field.
And,
uh,
and they reported a.
One of them was Thomas Seyfried at
Boston college and he was a,
a neuro genetics professor at Yale
University and then had moved to Boston
to expand it,
a ketogenic diet program for cancer.
And he told me,
you know,
what you're observing is damaged
mitochondria from cancer cells which
have damaged Mitochondria and if you
give them more oxygen,
it will produce proportionately more
reactive oxygen species and that
oxidative stress would essentially
trigger a necrosis and a pop ptosis in
the cell so they would be able cell
death at a level of oxygen that was
relatively nontoxic to the healthy
cells.
So,
and then we did some work with ketones
and saw that ketones were stopping the
growth of cancer too.
So we had this idea of using,
you know,
nutritional ketosis plus hyperbaric
oxygen and studying that in a mouse
model of cancer.
And,
uh,
and we've got some remarkable results
that we published and this is,
uh,
you know,
patients are doing this kind of a in an
off label way.
They're doing the Diet.
But now we have,
if we go to clinical trials dot Gov and
you just look up ketogenic diet,
you see more than a dozen studies,
you know.
So when I got into this,
there was no studies,
so now there's been an interest and even
maybe people like jumping on the
bandwagon of,
you know,
if they have a particular drug,
will accuse drank diet,
enhance it,
or let's see if it enhance it,
the standard of care or let's see,
we're standard of care failed.
If we can get these patients on this
metabolic therapy and see if we can help
them with quality of life.
It's so exciting.
I mean it's just really amazing,
exciting stuff.
It's so,
so interesting seeing something like
this emerge.
It'll relatively late in terms of like
medicine and science.
I mean 2017.
We're talking about something that's
diet.
Yep.
So just if you google like kidogenic
diet and a Google search around 2012,
it's down here and something happened
around 2013 or 14 or just skyrocketed it
was that.
Do you know?
I have no idea.
I mean,
I was on Tim Ferriss and other things,
but a lot of my colleagues,
so,
uh,
probably dating back to 2014,
20,
that could be,
but it's really my colleagues.
I mean there's so many humble,
so,
well,
you know,
I'm sure your colleagues have a lot to
do with it,
but as far as the impact of the impact
cast,
the impact that a podcast has in terms
of the amount of people that are going
to google something,
it's probably,
yeah,
many,
many magnitudes greater than anything
that anybody is doing,
you know,
from professor or,
some.
I realize that now.
So,
and I,
I thank you for letting me have this
platform.
But,
uh,
I,
I almost feel like there's guys like the
guy that got me into this was Dr Jiang
row and he was at Barrow Neurological
Institute.
He mentored my colleague Adrian check
into looking at ketones for
Glioblastoma.
He's runs the pediatric center in
Calgary Right now.
Uh,
but Dr Eric Kossoff from Johns Hopkins
was a big,
big help to me.
A number of people.
I feel like they should have this
platform,
but you know,
they're,
they're so busy they don't do podcasts,
but I realized fairly early on it was
really important to get the message out
because it does no good if you're not
hitting a big target.
And what I focused on was not just one
application,
but I mean we do everything from wound
healing to these genetic diseases to
cancer,
to various seizure disorders.
So I realized this was a lot bigger than
just pediatric epilepsy and uh,
and it's the only way you should eat it
is.
I mean,
I don't know,
tell everybody they should eat
ketogenic,
but I definitely feel that they should
at least go into ketosis a couple times
a year if not for just longevity effects
for anti inflammatory effects when,
um,
when things pop up and we're under
stress,
like a,
had an email yesterday,
a person had severe shingles or severe,
like a outbreaks of a,
even the,
like a fever blisters or something like
that,
or cold sores.
And if they just fast and do the
ketogenic diet,
it suppresses that.
Or when they had.
Since they've been on the Ketogenic
Diet,
they had profound suppression of some
viral disorders that when the virus,
when there's viral shedding and there's,
you know,
you're affected by the virus,
it causes profound,
uh,
in inflammation and neuroinflammation,
so it kind of starts with a headache and
then it will kind of lead to the
itchiness or whatever associated with
shingles,
but they described it very elegant,
you know,
elegantly in an email and it was very
clear,
you know,
before and after,
since they've been doing the ketogenic
diet had a profound effect even more so
than the drugs,
anti viral drugs that they're taking.
So even something like HIV,
which contributes to neuroinflammation
and even different types of cancers,
like a Kaposi Sarcoma,
I think,
uh,
being being in a state of nutritional
ketosis could probably offer a lot of
benefits to HIV patients that really
struggle,
you know,
with some symptoms that are associated
with inflammation and other things
associated.
So this is another path we're going into
it.
So some of those researchers has reached
out to us and say,
hey,
the NIH has a proposal for this.
Let's write a grant together.
So I'm in the like,
it's been,
it's crazy because I only have such so
much of a bandwidth,
but people from Ivy League institutions
are reaching out to me and saying,
Hey,
can you help us formulate a ketogenic
diet or can we use your ketone
supplement to do a study on things I
never thought,
you know,
a nutritional ketosis would be applied
to.
Now what about wound healing?
You brought up wound healing.
Yeah,
that's the big one.
Uh,
one of my students,
uh,
Dr Shannon Kessel,
she actually works for the epigenics
foundation now helping the dogs at the
Quito pet sanctuary.
She did her phd on the effects of
ketones on a wound healing model.
And the model that we use was,
uh,
essentially,
you know,
the back of a rat.
Hopefully there's,
you know,
animal protection people.
But,
but in describing what we do,
we basically have a wound that's a
pretty,
pretty nasty wound on the back of a rat
where one side is a schemic,
it lacks significant blood flow and the
other side is non ischemic.
And then which has normal blood flow and
there's like a chunk of tissue kind of
taken out and then we look to see how
fast that wound closes up right over
time and we do it in young animals and
we do in aged animals and we take
animals and then we feed them a standard
road in Chow,
which is high carbohydrate Roden Chow,
and then we have a number of different
groups where we give them various types
of ketone supplements.
And we found that,
uh,
admitted that the ketone supplements
enhance the wound healing not only in
the aged,
which was pretty remarkable and
ischemic,
but also in the young had event.
So it was like for the young healthy guy
that has a cut or a wound on the
battlefield or something like that,
it can help that wound heal up faster.
And it's doing it through a variety of
mechanisms.
Probably a,
the wound itself is often the,
the wound tissue is deficient in ATP.
The energy source because the blood
can't get to it.
Right?
So the ketones can restore like 90
percent of it has 90 percent less atp in
some cases we have ischemic wounds.
The ketones have the ability to like we
think,
thin out the blood and be able to get to
that wound tissue that's lacking oxygen
and blood flow and not only does it
restore the energy to the wound healing
which can allow cells to replicate and
heal up the wound faster,
but I talked about the anti inflammatory
effects.
So persistent chronic inflammation can
prevent the wound from healing up and by
suppressing some of the inflammatory
pathways that can kind of open the gate
on the activity of Eris growth factors
and healing processes that can heal the
wound up and it seems to be pretty
profound in the age,
but also happens in the young.
Now this is just taking exotic Pr Jones
and not even entered Chow from rodents,
standard child.
So we didn't want to kind of messy up
the the data in any way.
We actually should've done a well if we
had the funding,
we could have done a key to genic diet
plus keynote and supplementation.
And you think that would be been better?
Yeah,
I definitely think it would because the
ketogenic diet alone suppresses some of
these inflammatory components that,
that is associated with impaired wound
healing,
especially impaired wound healing in
like a diabetic model.
So I talked about hyperbaric oxygen
therapy,
the main applications that is for
diabetic wounds that don't heal up
because the oxygen and glucose doesn't
get to it.
Uh,
so in the diabetic wound,
the problem is that,
uh,
it's really a blood flow problem and we
did to answer that question that
determine if it was blood flow.
We did a doppler blood flow analysis of
the blood flow into wound and showed
that it was something like a 25 or 30
percent increase in blood flow to the
wound when we induced acute ketosis.
So we'd given jd incredible,
we stimulate,
you know,
ketosis that would mimic Qj diet or
fasting.
And then we do a doppler blood flow
analysis and we show a pretty remarkable
increase in.
That's a huge increase.
Yeah.
That's being.
That seems like that would be the move
for someone who's recovering from some
sort of research or something,
a hyperbaric chamber combined with
Ketosis mutagenic and for the Va.
My collaborator on this project,
dr lisa gold at one time,
she was the,
she was the president of the wound
healing society.
And even she was like,
this is really reMarkable.
I mean,
to have someone of her stature,
she's an md phd,
a really comment that this is profound,
you know,
effect on wound healing really motivated
us to follow up on this.
but,
uh,
we have not gotten funding after that,
so we really need to keep working
because we need to follow up on this
study,
uh,
and get this as a legitimate wound to a
lot of people are trying to enhance the
wound healing process by putting things
on the wound,
you know,
but we're wound healing is enhanced if
you alter and optimize your metabolic
physiology that promotes,
you know,
substrate and oxygenation to the wound,
and that's what ketones do.
I mean,
you have a vasodilation effect.
There is a big increase in a denison.
Denison is a pretty profound vasodilator
dilator,
so you have a vasodilation that's
improving blood flow to the area where
there's not only glucose in there,
but there's ketones and ketones help
restore the energy in that wound that is
sufficiently depressed from lack of
blood flow and it's promoting or
reducing a lot of the inflammatory
things that are preventing it from
healing in the first place.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I mean this was really like it was
presented at the wound healing society
and they were,
a lot of people were floored by it.
So it's.
Shannon has a,
my student has went and moved on and
doing postdoctoral work at another
place,
but I really need to follow up on that.
We have a lot of projects,
you know,
we're trying to process in parallel
right now,
but yeah,
I neeD another student to,
to,
because that may have been,
you know,
that.
And you know,
some of the motor function,
gLucose lowering and antianxiety effects
are all thinGs that kinda jumped out of
the data from us that I like never would
have expected,
you know,
is I came in this to look at seizures
now.
What was the hard data in terms of like
what is the percentage of increase in
healing across the board with the,
with the routes.
So if we look at time time for that
wound to close and heal up,
it's about 20,
20 to 25 percent.
That's significant mirrors.
The amount of blood flow that you were
talking about,
the increase in blood flow big about 20
percent does.
I don't know if you could draw a direct
correlation to that,
but obviously if you have improved blood
flow that's getting nutrition to the
wound,
uh,
and we know that that blood has ketones
in it which have anti inflammatory
effects and things like,
you know,
it stimulates a,
the h deck,
each tech one and two,
which stimulates superoxide dismutase,
another antioxidant enzymes which are
often dysregulated,
you know,
at the wound site.
So it's doing a lot of,
not only just restoring oxygenation and
blood flow,
but it's having like a drug like effects
these metabolites are really like
signaling and it makes sense like,
you know,
if we're in a state of starvation,
ketosis,
the ketones would have,
you know,
be telling the brain to do certain
things and different neuro
pharmacological pathways that it should
be altering our behavior in ways you
don't want to.
The person that is deprived of food and
becomes tired from hypoglycemia and qa
is the person that's going to die.
So the people that survived in the
absence of food availability were the
ones that became more lucid and clear
and we were able to go and forage or
hunt down the animal and kill it and eat
it.
So we Are hardwired.
I mean,
to answer your question,
I think a while back you asked,
you know,
why,
why do we have ketones?
Why?
I think it's an evolutionarily hardwired
system that,
uh,
is just built into our dna.
And,
uh,
you know,
with the advent of carbohydrates and
frequent feedings and you know,
a deli on every corner here,
we've largely silenced that genetic
program that becomes activated upon food
deprivation that can stimulate a host of
beneficial things from extension of
longevity to autophagy.
And no,
rhonda,
patrick,
you know,
and I'm a big fan of her,
she's talked about this a quite a lot
and she's awesome.
And uh,
yeah,
she's super awesome.
She actually visited the lab and we did
a podcast with her at our lab.
Yeah.
She's just scares the shit out of me.
Every time I talked to her I'm like,
basically a monkey knows the same
languages.
Her,
she's like an encyclopedia of
information.
Uh,
and she always come prepared.
So I came prepared.
I was like,
yeah,
I should do it.
Rhonda does.
So I wrote down some notes here.
I probably,
there's probably things I'll forget,
but um,
but yeah,
so yeah,
it's,
it's a system that typically was
activated in the normal person,
you know,
uh,
during periods of millennia ago.
Yeah.
And actually enhanced your
concentratIon.
Absolutely.
That's one of the things,
to go back to the hunting thing,
my friend remy warren,
who's a pretty famous,
a hunter and one of them,
one of the things that he says,
and he's always said this,
that he likes to hunt hungry and one of
the things he does,
he does these back pump back country
hunting trips solo and he purposely
brings to little food.
Yeah.
On one of the things that he's found
over his many years is that when he is
actually hungry is more tuned in and he
does a better job of understanding
what's going on.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Like the first time I actually started
experimenting with fasting or even a
calorie restricted diet.
I took a walk around my neighborhood at
the time and it's like my whole nostrils
opened up.
I could smell things.
I could hear things.
I was more lucid in ways I had not been
before,
uh,
even fasted for seven days and was able
to give a lecture and train in the gym
and lift weights that were not hardly
much lower than what I typically do.
So I probably couldn't.
Do you know,
it was just at seven day per point after
no calories.
I was starting to freeze at all,
no galleries after seven days,
just water,
water and some,
uh,
like a bullying cube,
so some electrolytes like sodium
potassium and lots of water and I allow
myself a,
about a third of the coffee that I would
typically drink.
So I'd have a small cup of coffee in the
morning and I got a ton of stuff done
during that week.
Like I had,
you know,
because I didn't have to,
to make my food,
I didn't have to clean up my food,
I didn't have time eating the food.
So I saved a lot of time.
Uh,
I think I lost eight to nine pounds and
then within a week or two it,
it all came back again.
You know,
a lot of it's new,
you're holding glycogen and,
and you lose like a.
But uh,
in regards to,
you know,
at the time I'm like,
my deadlift strength was maybe eight
reps for eight or 10 reps with like five
65.
and I was able to do 10 easy reps with
five plates on each side,
which is about 500.
Uh,
and you know,
typically going into this,
I was parenthood when I was,
you know,
I followed,
I listened to [inaudible] podcast and I
was a huge follower during aids in 1994.
And I was eating.
So I was eating four to six meals a day
with shakes in between.
And I remember even having like
nightmares,
I would wake up in the middle nightmare.
Like the nightmare would be.
I didn't have like food on me after two
hours.
Like I would have to eat like every two.
I was so obsessed with getting bigger
and stronger.
And so for me to fast seven days and to
be out of my comfort zone,
that was like a big step for me.
So I kinda just did it to mentally
liberate myself from chronic overfeeding
and things.
And because I was,
I had just read and studied george
cahill and the harvard medical school
study where they fasted for 40 days and
I'm looking at,
you know,
all the parameters on that.
And I was like,
it's not going to kill me,
it's probably going to do me well.
And uh,
the more I did it,
the second and third day we're,
we're kinda hard for me.
But after like the fifth day it became,
it was bizarre.
It became like really easy and I was
just kind of like floating around like,
like my body had no inflammation.
Uh,
I wasn't buzzing with energy,
but I was very lucid and I didn't feel
like I need it to be buzzed.
Like I realized I'm so much,
but a lot of times I feel like I need to
drink coffee to amp up to be my best.
But I was my best when my brain was
really calm and I was able to put
thoughts together.
And I wrote a whole lot of research
proposals which later became funded,
you know,
and I got probably of the proposals I
really worked on.
It probably got over a million dollars
of funding during that time.
I really intensely worked on,
on various proposals because I just
transitioned into like a tenure track
position.
So it allowed me to work on manuscripts
and proposals and just put thoughts
together that maybe I otherwise either
wouldn't have the time to or the mental
kind of resources to get into that
counter intuitive that you have more
resources with less calories.
It does.
I mean,
you know,
I was burning my body fat for fuel
primarily.
Probably lost a little bit of muscle,
but that fuel,
that fat was becoming ketones and that
my brain had switched over.
I was doing low carB but not really full
full quito at the time.
But it really,
it's like quieted my brain in a way that
I was able to really.
Maybe I have like mild adhd because I
like to do so many different things.
But it quieted my mind and I was able to
wake up like every morning I was waking
up a lot earlier than normal,
like 4:35
and I typically sleep till like seven.
But I was able to like wake up and just
focus and get a ton of work done the
first three or four hours.
and then then I would go into work
actually.
And just,
you know,
meet with my students or teach or do
whatever I had to do,
but I just remember getting a ton of
work done during that period.
I've never reproduced it.
I never went back and,
but I did a whole bunch of blood work on
me to give,
you know,
a little bit of insight as to what's
going on during,
uh,
during the fasting stage and everything
was really positive.
You know,
there was a big,
uh,
my insulin was really low at the time.
My glucose was really low.
I got down to like 25 at one point
because I,
I've experimented with a couple of
different things and my ketones were
really high.
My ketones were like double what my
glucose was at a couple time points
during that.
So it's an edge.
I would,
I would encourage people,
especially maybe people that are prone
to cancer or people who have had cancer
in the past and maybe had treated and
are kind of in a state of remission.
Uh,
if you go,
if you get your body into that,
what we call the metabolic zone,
where the level of ketones are higher
than the level of glucose,
that puts tremendous metabolic stress on
cancer cells or precancerous cells that
have a huge appetite for glucose,
so,
and that contribute can,
can initiate autophagy.
So even people who do not have cancer,
but perhaps you want to just make sure
they're holding off of it as a
preventative maintenance.
Yup.
And I think it can stimulate almost
purge your body of cancer cells that are
weakened by in this fasted state and
also precancerous cells that may be in
the transition of trends,
you know,
d differentiating into this.
No cancer like cells.
These cells are very energy demanding,
especially if they're replicating.
And if you deprive them of energy,
the quote unquote energy crisis signal
that these cells receive can,
can initiate a program,
cell death we call apoptosis and
autophagy.
And that's the benefit of this.
It's almost like housekeeping.
So think about it,
you know,
you accumulate a lot of dead cells that
are kind of sluggish or mitochondria
kind of sluggish.
And then you fast for a week and it's
like reboot.
It's like a setting.
It's like a reset button.
So did you,
um,
I,
I had,
I did a podcast with robb wolf or he was
talking about this morning,
god who went for a whole year without
eating.
Did you,
if you pay attention to that?
Not,
not only did I pay attention to it,
I've presented that at a number of
different meetings and people,
people say bullshit.
But this is actually a,
it's in a.
oh man.
I think I,
I may have had it.
I was going to actually show it at this,
uh,
at this meeting.
But I think I took the slide out.
I had it in his back.
people with this guy did 382 days.
Not only did he lose a tremendous amount
of weight,
he went from being morbidly obese to
being like a normal sized person.
But here's the big one.
The skin shrink.
Yeah.
That's normally one of the most part.
Yeah,
for the most part.
I mean significantly.
We're,
most people have to.
When you're that big and you shrink down
to a normal sized person,
they have to cut your skin or you just
walk around like a flying squirrel and
when you have like this crazy extra
skin,
right?
Yeah.
Well this guy,
somehow or another through this 380 plus
days of fasting,
his body shrank accordingly.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
So he was about 500 pounds,
actually,
travis christofferson and I wrote a blog
article and it was part one,
two and three,
the history of the key to genic diet,
part one,
two and three.
And it's on rob wolf website.
So if you just googled the history of
the ketogenic diet and land on rob's
website,
you'll have,
I think we talk about the story in
there.
Uh,
it's a remarkable story.
Yeah.
The guy was like 500 pounds and he
fasted for like 381 days or 82 days and
he went down to 190 pounds.
And the remarkable thing is that he
sustained that over.
I mean,
he maybe went back,
went back up like five or six pounds,
but largely sustain that weight loss,
that's the quarter time.
So he was running completely all fat,
the fat that he had stored up and uh,
and he was studied pretty intensely and
the thing that came out of the data was
a,
it was a pretty significant drop in
magnesium.
So that actually convinced me.
Yeah,
I definitely should probably maybe
supplement magnesium was fasting
anything,
any vitamins or they did give him an
electrolyte.
So it's in the medical records and I dug
into this as much as we could.
Uh,
his glucose levels got down to like 20
or 25 a couple times and maintained it
was given potassium tablets to keep his
heart healthy and multivitamins every
day.
Yep.
I'm just rough.
You have done is it robs?
Yeah.
I think I've seen this,
but yeah,
fast at 300,
82 days.
A incredible last 275 point five pounds
now.
Who was calling bullshit on this?
Well,
I did present it to a,
like a mainstream,
you know,
clinicians even just coughing.
Well,
it's actually really fun,
like the first it might've been the
american epilepsy society where they
kind of marginalized the ketogenic diet
or it may have been another,
it might've been neurology and epilepsy
society at the time.
They're warming up to it just because
the data,
they can't,
they can't turn their back on the data
because data is data.
So there's a massive amount of data
emerging that this should,
uh,
this is grossly underutilized and should
be really the standard of care.
Even the frontline therapy,
like we all kind of realized,
but neurologists would have to have a
sidekick registered dietician or
whatever.
But,
but so during the time one of my first
presentations was to a medical doctors,
you know,
that we're in it for cme credits and
things like that.
Like just standard conventional.
And I talked about,
you know,
towards the end I was like,
well,
I followed the ketogenic diet myself and
they're like,
they're like gas or like,
oh,
what's wrong with you?
It's like when I explained to them that
I was normal in the question answering
after were like,
well why do you do it?
And was like,
are you okay?
This is going back like 2009 or 10 years
ago.
It was really bizarre to them that
someone would actually fall the
ketogenic diet.
And I was doing like the classical,
I was trying to do like the,
you know,
the,
the hopkins protocol or was using eric
kossoff spoke on the,
on the op 98 and two.
Uh,
I was,
I was about 80,
I was a three to one,
so it was like 85 to 88 percent fat and
I was sticking to it.
And uh,
yeah,
so people really just think it's a
really bizarre,
if you don't have a severe neurological
problem to be at the time and now that's
just evidence of how mainstream because
you,
you know,
you see it in mass media,
athletes going on quote unquote the
ketogenic diet.
I'd question whether they're actually
ketogenic.
Uh,
they need another measure of their
ketones to really.
So the ketogenic diet,
you're in ketosis by virtue,
by the definition that your blood
ketones are elevated above zero point
five millimolar.
And typically most people,
that's pretty hard to achieve.
If you're up to one millimolar,
which is mild ketosis,
you take a hundred people out of the
population,
they eat the standard american diet,
maybe one,
maybe two people will achieve that if
they like go all day without eating or
something like it really takes a while
to achieve.
So you have to be doing something pretty
radical to achieve that blood
measurement of a state of ketosis and
not seeing that in pro athletes.
So I know there's a few fighters we
should take before she retired.
She went ketogenic,
uh,
her boyfriend,
brian caraway.
I know he was key to genic for awhile.
That's just my experience with athletes,
but I know that there was a lot of
people that are looking at it.
Yeah,
I would,
you know,
kind of questioned whether they were
like kidogenic.
I'm sure they did low carb,
but if you eat too much protein that
converts to glucose,
it can kick you out.
But,
but then again,
I mean I,
some,
some athletes that contact me,
their output is really high so they're
actually giving like five or six hours
of output a day and they're eating like
two or three chocolate bars and they're
getting like 250 grams of carbs a day,
some of them.
And there's maintaining a mild state of
ketosis,
especially post exercise ketosis.
Even with drinking suddenly something
like that,
you can start like a slow burning like a
soup,
like a slow carb,
like a tim ferris advocates,
uh,
and they stay in ketosis and if they
back off more,
if they back their carbohydrates down to
like 50 grams a day,
they start to lose performance on that.
I mean these are people with very high
output though.
Ridiculous.
Yeah.
We talked about five hours of exercise a
day plus,
and they went from a thousand grams of
carbs a day to 250 and better.
Fifty grams of carbs for the standard
average person.
This is not applicable for an mma
fighter is two and three days.
Uh,
I think,
I think you could,
especially the older guys like older
guys,
I think you could readily adapt them.
Like I said though,
I think that adaptation should probably
occur during training in the off season
and give themselves a buffer zone of
three months and actually work with a
coach or work with an app,
uh,
like avatar nutrition or something where
they calculate the macros and they
actually know they're hitting the
macros.
And the body is amazing.
If you actually hit the macros that are
calculated,
your body will go into ketosis.
I've never seen.
There's very few people that you can't
get into quito,
especially if you use things like mct
and really adjust the macros.
And you could also do key to key to
genic intermittent fasting where you
kind of don't eat throughout the day but
then eat through a window or time
restricted eating as a rhonda.
patrick calls it where you basically
just eat within,
you know,
a,
a six hour window.
And I like to do that.
I'll eat from 5:00
PM to 11:00
PM and just kind of eat a big meal and
just kind of graze a little bit
throughout and then I get,
you know,
a pretty good chunk of the time fasting.
And then after I'm done with work,
you know,
I'm not frantically running around
trying to get stuff done so I can relax
with my wife and just kind of kicked
back and eat and just,
you know.
And that's kinda what I wanna eat
anyway.
So you feel like there's more of a I'm
doing a 14 hour thing you think is even
more benefit doing an 18?
I do.
I think,
you know,
I don't,
uh,
I do uh,
for,
for me I definitely think I do a because
there's something about like a couple
hours extra where like if I fast for 14
hours but then go like my ketones really
start to go up from 14 to 18 hours and
then.
And then I could actually stay in
ketosis if I eat key to genic during
that six hours of eating.
If I kind of pay attention to,
you know,
eating really low carb like I can eat
and before I go to bed I test my ketones
and bam,
I'm hitting like two point two or
something,
so I continued to get the benefits of
having ketones,
but when it comes to like things like
rhonda talks about like autology,
I think you can even get more benefits
with an 18 hour fast and you do that and
you'll have to do it every day.
I think you could just do it.
Like you could actually do it just once,
maybe twice a week and get a lot of
benefits from that.
Like if you do that over the course of a
year and that's not hard to do,
right?
If you could just convince people,
hey,
take the breads and pastas out and just
put in more vegetables and just do
intermittent fasting.
You know,
every,
every tuesday and thursday.
And if they do blood work after like
three months,
they're going to see a profound effect.
Probably not even changing the diet.
They're going to see.
A profound effect now is someone told me
that there is an effective way to
measure ketones through breathing.
There's some sort of a breath monitor.
Is that,
is that real or?
Yeah,
there's a couple of,
uh,
some of them were being showcased at the
conference.
I was at the low carb usa.
I'm the one that I have the most
experience with is a product called
ketone x and uh,
and now they have a bluetooth device out
where you can blow into it and it
reports to your phone and it shows you,
shows you the parts per million of
acetone in there and acetone.
So you make beta hydroxybutyrate nsc to
acetate as the two primary ketone bodies
that are used for fuel.
And also they have signaling properties
and acetoacetate can break down a
spontaneously decarboxylates to
something called acetone,
which you knows,
nail polish remover.
Right?
So a acetone actually has some really
interesting a brain effects that calms
the brain down a sub narcotic levels of
acetone,
a open potassium channels that when
potassium channels are opened that
hyperpolarizes the membrane potential
for neurons and makes them kind of more
like charged batteries and it also kinda
calms your,
your brain down.
So iT's not firing action potentials as
much and that's a good thing.
So instead of all this kind of
fluttering of activity,
it helps to kind of synchronize your
brain in a way by elevating.
And this goes back to homeostasis,
right?
So that acetone has,
can correlate with seizure control.
So parents who have kids who do not like
to get their fingers pricked,
have used the breath.
Acetone,
you blow into it,
you get a pretty color,
you know the kids like it and
everything.
It is kinD of hard to like set it up,
you've got to calibrate it.
And so it's a little bit clunky to work
with but it does pretty good indicator
if you're registering like orange or red
on that,
you are definitely in a state of
ketosis.
So.
But I call it only semi quantitative,
so they need to work out some of the
bugs and if you just look up breath
acetone meters,
there's probably about five on the
market now.
And the one that I have experienced with
is called a key tonics.
And if you're acetone is high and you're
not taking ketone supplements,
you are burnt.
You are cranking your fat metabolism,
you are really,
you know,
mobilizing fat and burning fat for
energy.
So it's a pretty valid indicator for
burning fat for energy.
Blood is the best.
Bloods of gold standard probably will
always be.
there's technologies emerging out now at
least you know,
small companies that are a essentially
a,
you put a like a bandaid like thing on
your skin and it's measuring glucose.
It's measuring a,
you know,
potentially beta hydroxybutyrate
acetoacetate and things like lactate.
And then it'll go to your smartphone.
So you can look at your smartphone and
see your glucose levels,
your,
your ketones,
your lactate,
and maybe some potentially other things
you could adjust your diet or drink a
supplement to optimize you into a,
you know,
maximizes your strength,
maximize your performance,
or maximizes your brain protection in
extreme environment like high pressure
oxygen or a navy seal or something like
that.
That technology is in development now
and will probably surface sometime in
the next year or two.
And I think it will be pretty cool.
So think of a dexcon,
but instead of just glucose,
it'll give you like a metabolomic
profile of your blood.
And then there'll be,
you know,
you can augment it in with your diet or
with various supplements.
Now I've got two other important
questions.
One physical performance.
Um,
have there been studies on reaction time
on all sorts of different variables that
I think,
I mean if you're looking at all of this,
increase in blood flow,
decrease in inflammation,
all those things are what you would want
out of a body that you want to perform
better.
It seems like things would fire better
as it will,
for lack of a better word,
what have there been studies on putting
athletes through variety,
stress tests,
reaction times,
things along those lines,
those
studies need to be done.
And I think at some of the marketers out
there that are promoting ketone
supplements are based on some animal
data and I think they're extrapolating
some of the effects.
Will ketones offer a metabolic
advantage?
You know,
they can,
you can generate more atp.
You can,
it gives your brain resilience under
inflammation or hyperglycemia.
uh,
but the,
the bottom line is that these studies
need to be done and they need to be
funded.
Some of them are going on right now and
some of them are.
I'm kind of involved in a.
And probably most important is,
you know,
what are they actually studying?
Like what,
what key to genic diet are they actually
studying?
Like what are the macronutrient ratios,
not only the ratios,
but what types of fats are they using,
you know,
what type,
what's their protein source,
you know?
Uh,
and that's really important.
And when it comes to ketone supplements,
like that's a whole nother box of worms
are,
I mean,
are they using,
you know,
just pure sodium,
beta hydroxy butyrate,
are they using like sodium potassium,
magnesium combination which would offer
more benefits?
Uh,
are they really using [inaudible] for if
the dna or are they using a ketone
ester?
So there's like lots of these,
uh,
considerations.
There's lots of nuances,
you know,
in the way these things are formulated
in the way they're dosed and in what
type of application,
whether it's a pure strength application
or what I call strength performance,
like pushups and chin ups and things
like that,
like a or endurance or ultra endurance
or things like that.
So do a lot of research needs to be
done.
So I didn't really give you an answer,
but I think the guy who's done the most
research on this clearly,
at least with the ketogenic diet,
is Jeff Bullock from Ohio state
university.
His faster study clearly showed that
athletes in a state of nutritional
ketosis burn like,
you know,
almost twice the amount of fat,
and they maintain that,
which is remarkable.
I mean,
does some elegant studies to show fat
oxford vaccination rates are like double
of what we even thought were achievable
when guys follow a well formulated
ketogenic diet and he recently did a
study,
a using a ketone salt product showing
that there was an enhancement of eight
percent performance in workout.
Put a with a cyclist.
So big number.
April is pretty big for cyclists.
Yeah,
it might've been time to exhaustion.
He just presented it here.
I didn't even know he had the data
actually,
but I mean jeff volek is the leading
researcher on and he wrote the book the
art and science of low carbohydrate
performance,
which a lot of mma guys have benefited
from because they emailed me.
Uh,
but these,
these are studies that I'm really
interested.
I mean we've done a lot of work in
animal models and now we're
transitioning to a human studies.
We have a study at duke university,
so I mentioned a oxygen toxicity to
study this,
you know,
in humans in these big environmental
chambers at duke.
And then we do some stuff with nasa and
the nasa neemo mission.
I was on a,
but we're really interested in moving a
lot of these animal studies,
which we've done.
Now we're ready to move into humans,
but we still don't know what the optimal
supplement is and that's why a ketone
technologies,
a company we developed this really
focused on identifying not the
supplement that gives us the best
margins for sales,
but the supplement that's super
optimized for particular applications.
Now another question I wanted to ask you
was about migraines.
Now I would assume that people with
headaches,
you take nonsteroidal anti
inflammatories.
Someone with migraines mean it would,
it would seem to me that that would be
something that might be able to help
mitigate.
Yeah.
Um,
there's a student,
I'm on her dissertation committee,
uh,
elena gross and she was a student,
graduated from oxford university and is
now doing a clinical trial on a ketone
salts for migraine.
So what motivated her to even pursue
this as a phd project is that she had
crippling cluster migraine headaches and
she reached out to me and,
uh,
she actually presented at our metabolic
therapeutics conference and that's her
area of expertise.
Like when it's happening to you
personally,
it motivates you in a way that you just
immerse yourself in the research and you
become like a leading expert and I think
at the,
at the very young age that elena is,
and she's got a great background of
education behind her.
She's kind of the leading authority on
nutritional ketosis for,
for migraines,
which is a growing field because a lot
of people who had migraines that have
contacted me and tried either of the
ketogenic diet or ketone supplementation
have benefited from it when nothing else
worked for them.
It doesn't work for everybody,
but in some people that have these
crippling headaches,
it better than anything that they've
tried so far.
Um,
and migraines,
uh,
some of the data coming out,
there's two sets of data that I've seen
showing that migraines are linked to
neuroinflammation.
Uh,
for example,
if it's caused by a viral etiology,
there's kind of swelling of the brain
that leads to this kind of low systemic
neuroinflammation.
and maybe the ketones are working
through an anti a and anti inflammatory
effects.
Uh,
sometimes like I said before,
people get shingles or like a cold list
or they'll get like a headache
throughout the day and that's probably
neuroinflammation and then there's other
data to show that these migraines
actually may be like a mini seizure,
like your brain is actually having a
mini seizure that's not manifesting as a
grand mal or tonic clonic seizure or
even an absence seizure,
but it's,
but it's presenting as a migraine and
it's seizure.
Like I would say some of the data is
indicating that and ketones seem to be a
viable strategy for,
uh,
you know,
for migraines from what I've seen.
and that's why it's being studied right
now.
The other question is,
what about someone who's on a vegan
diet?
Yeah,
I get to a lot.
I have a really close friend.
Uh,
she's vegetarian.
I'm dr don carnegie as a ihmc.
We've talked about this a lot for a
vegetarian,
it's relatively easy,
right?
Because you had a dairy and you have
eggs and eggs are a huge staple.
I buy the happy eggs,
which actually tastes a lot better.
They're like the free range egg a,
but a vegan diet is a little more
challenging.
The charlie foundations,
a dietitian beth zoo pack,
Kenya is her name.
Uh,
if you go to the charlie foundation
website,
I think you may be able to find some
information or a pamphlet that describes
how to put together a vegan,
a kidogenic diet.
So there's no way that you can hit the
macronutrient ratios,
have a key to genic diet that's vegan
unless it's in a shake form.
So in this case,
you know,
formulating a product that's more of an
illiquid form that you can drink is
probably the way to go.
If you do do a vegan ketogenic diet,
whole food,
the best that you could do Is really
about maybe 60 percent fat,
maybe 70 percent fat,
and if you formulate the diet with
coconut oil and mct,
that'll get your ketones up.
And then if you consume,
you know,
one of these,
uh,
various products on the market that are
essentially medical foods or drinks that
you can drink,
you know,
you can stay in nutritional ketosis.
So it's a,
it's a struggle.
It's,
it's possible,
but it's way much,
much harder.
People do do it though,
then they follow a vegan for ethical
reasons or for a cultural reasons and
they've been able to do it.
But vegetarian is doable of vegetarian
is very doable with eggs.
If you can use eggs and dairy.
I tend to minimize dairy in my diet but
yeah,
so eggs are huge.
So you minimize dairy because of the
effect it has on you or like a lot of
dairy protein like way it kinda started
with whey protein and I drank it for
years and maybe I just built up an
allergy to it.
But if I were to drink like a full shake
of whey protein right now it would make
it wouldn't agree with nigga.
Uh,
although I can,
I can eat butter and sour cream a fine,
no problem.
And a lot of dairy proteins,
especially casing if I eat a sour cream
or cottage cheese.
Cottage cheese.
Yeah.
So something about that can start to
irritate my gut a little bit.
So I generally just minimize it.
I do like cheese is kind of a weakness
for me.
So I might get a little bit of cheese
here and there,
like almost every day even when I'm
home,
but uh,
but I know dairy really was the
cornerstone of the cute agentic diet
with the original ketogenic diet with
the,
like what johns hopkins was formulating
because it's been so easy and it tastes
good,
right?
Uh,
but I do find that when people are
following the qj diet for weight loss
and they kind of pulled out the dairy,
their fat loss increases.
So I've observed that kind of
anecdotally,
I'm not sure if people have studied it,
but if they just,
for example,
pull out the heavy cream and put in a
concentrated coconut milk,
which I use for my heavy cream,
which almost has a same cream,
like consistency and they take out the
butter,
maybe use more coconut oil and just kind
of switch out dairy for other things,
their fat loss and something about dairy
in some people.
Not everybody,
uh,
maybe caused them to retain water.
Might be like a mild allergan.
So for me,
I'm okay with it as long as I kind of
minimize it,
but I've just heard so many stories.
One,
uh,
there was a case report,
now have a mother who had an autistic
child and put them on a ketogenic diet
and did remarkably well and then made it
dairy free and it was really the dairy
that was contributing to some of the
symptoms.
So I think,
and this went,
this is in the medical literature,
it's like on pub med,
she use a dairy free ketogenic diet and
had quote unquote remission in an
autistic child.
I firSt saw it,
presented an abstract at a meeting and I
was like,
wow.
It was really blown away.
And then about a year later it came out
and it was in a pretty good,
uh,
pretty good journal as a peer reviewed
publication and pretty well documented
case report of putting an autistic child
into remission with acute junk dot.
so we talk about emerging applications.
I know my colleagues,
uh,
dr jiang roe and dr susan massino are
studying,
and I mentioned this because they get so
many emails about it.
The ketogenetic diet for autism,
so I think many things are.
Could be the next frontier formation.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It could be lending if diet,
you know,
reduces inflammation and if diet without
dairy reduces inflammation further that
I know a lot of people are having some
great effects with cbd oils,
which again,
reduce inflammation.
Something I'm very interested in.
Yeah.
I've talked to a nation.
It's just such a giant factor in,
in negative health consequences.
Ketogenic diet plus a cbd,
a plus hyperbaric oxygen therapy plus
ketones supplementation is something
that I wanted to study in a brain tumor
model.
A,
I've just gotten too many emails from
parents that have kids with epilepsy and
also people who have cancer who use cbd
oil and they felt it was remarkably
effective for them.
So,
uh,
I've talked with the ceo of charlotte's
web and other cbd right here.
Yo,
I've never actually tried.
Is that the charlotte?
Their brand.
So is this a standardize for a certain
level of thc?
It's below a certain level.
Is each batch and standardized.
It doesn't get you high.
That's what you mean?
Yeah.
Okay.
So that was sort of the problem I tried
to do is work with our university and
then I need a dea number and it was like
all the students had to have a d and it
became so much red tape,
but I'm going to revisit this project
and I'm sure you reconnect with them,
try to connect you if you like,
because they're actually a sponsor of
the podcast real and yeah,
they sent me a bunch of it and I tried
it out for awhile before I took them on
as a sponsor.
I'm like,
this stuff's legit.
yeah.
Read up about it.
You know,
they,
they use the whole plant as well.
So it has all the canals,
the other cannabinoids.
Yeah.
Which I think is important.
Uh,
you know,
there's companies that have patented the
specific can have a dial on there and
that's kind of,
I was going to use that and there's a
lot of,
you know,
da regulation even on that I think.
But yeah,
I will.
I'm going to revisit that project
because I really think,
uh,
some of the things that we do with the
diet and supplementation will synergize,
uh,
either be additive or synergistic with
cbd and I mean,
I love this idea of developing very
powerful therapies that make the patient
come out more healthy or does not
cripple their immune system or their
general health when they come out the
other side,
especially with cancer.
It's just absolutely incredible that you
could have a more robust person.
Yes.
Therapy.
Absolutely.
I think it's possible.
Yeah.
So With cancer it is tricky,
like every person is different,
but if you get a robust like healthy
person to begin with and you can develop
a therapy that manages their tumor.
Uh,
and I've seen very healthy per people
come out severely crippled after rounds
of chemo.
I've seen people killed with chemo.
I mean,
I know quite a few people actually,
sadly,
that have been killed literally by the
standard of care.
And this,
uh,
you should really have my colleague on
here.
He's a very dynamic speaker,
a little bit controversial in some ways,
but dr.
Professor thomas seyfried from boston
college,
he wrote the book cancer as a metabolic
disease and uh,
it's a fantastic book that,
you know,
elegantly documents the theory of cancer
as a metabolic disease,
uh,
with a lot of hard data.
And travis christofferson,
I wrote a book called tripping over the
truth and I wrote the foreword to the
book which discusses a why we view
cancer as a genetic disease and kind of
lays out the data and um,
you know,
all the evidence to support cancer as a
metabolic disease and what we should
most importantly like what we can do
about that in regards and that has major
implications for not only how we treat
cancer,
but how we prevent cancer.
so I talked about,
you know,
fasting to purge your body,
have precancerous cells so it would fall
in line with that.
But there's really good hard data
behind,
you know,
this idea that cancer is not,
maybe not necessarily all cancers are,
you know,
metabolic and origin,
but a large majority of them appear to
be.
And uh,
and I think the national cancer
institute and other organizations are
aware of this.
And now they're funding more grants that
actually target cancer metabolism and
even developing metabolic therapy
clinics for,
you know,
targeting tumor metabolism.
So this,
this was never,
this never happened,
you know,
a seven,
eight years ago when I got into this,
it was kind of unheard of,
but there's a lot of interest now in
pharmaceutical companies developing
these target molecules that inhibit
specific glycolytic sugar consuming
pathways.
So as evidence.
So the [inaudible] diet is great,
right?
because it hits many pathways and
synergy,
like one of my slides,
you know,
that I have and my conversation or a in
the presentations that I do is clearly
shows like it could see all the boxes
there.
So this is the key to drink diet and
these are all the different signaling
pathways that is working through.
And I would say pharmaceutical companies
may put billions of dollars just into
one of those little boxes.
You know,
the key to genIc diet works.
It's so powerful because it's many
different,
as many different,
uh,
signaling is many different pathways.
Kind of working in synergy for a common
output in this particular slide was the
neuro pharmacological effect that it has
on suppressing seizures.
the anticonvulsant effect.
Wow.
So,
and each one of these is validated with
a number of peer reviewed publications
that you can bring up on pub med.
So it's not like something some guy put
together,
I mean it's published and it's like you
go to pub med o hdac activity.
Okay.
But you knew it was like a half dozen
publications to support each one of
these.
So that's what's really exciting to me
because there's just so much to be kind
of discovered and so many different
applications and like I said,
it feeds back to nutrition,
which was like one of the main things
that motivated me,
you know,
early on in college.
So I can do,
you know,
go back to something I'm really
passionate about,
but it's all fascinating,
man across the board.
Uh,
and thank you for sharing this man.
Thank you.
Thanks for giving me the platform.
Thanks for going on the tim ferriss
show.
And without that I would've probably
been her for that.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Thanks tim,
and if somebody wanted to get started
with this,
what's the best resource,
like what do you think would be the best
way to do it?
And I got a few,
so I would say just go to our website.
I have a website,
quito,
nutrition,
all one word.org.
And on that website I have a list of
resources from ebooks to.
I mean there's ketogenic pizza,
there's a link.
Make cute agentic pizza.
What's a.
yeah,
I mean the almond flour,
the crust is essentially like a,
like chicken and parmesan cheese pounded
into like a cross where they put,
you know the,
the cheese and the sauce on a low carb
sauce on top of that.
Yeah,
I love this stuff.
It's real foods.
A company is.
I think someone told me that they're in
ralph's here,
so I guess they're really doing.
They're doing really well,
but I'll have like one or two of those
for breakfast in the morning,
especially if I'm kind of on the go.
They taste,
they're legit,
they're really,
really good.
Like,
I vetted out a lot of things and just
kind of very particular towards things
that I really like and actually tested.
So this is something that I've kind of
tested with blood work.
Uh,
so kiddo nutrition.org
at a link there.
If you click on that link,
it's,
you get a discount on,
uh,
on the,
product.
Uh,
max love project is really,
I mean,
if there's families out there,
parents out there that have kids that
have cancer,
please contact the max love project and
they are helping so many families
through innovative application of the
key to genic diet for childhood cancers.
Uh,
virta health.
So type two diabetes is like the
elephant in the room is a massive
project.
Virta health is basically tackling this
project,
uh,
by curing literally quote unquote
reversing type two diabetes,
uh,
in up to 100 million people in the next
decade.
I think that's really.
And I talked about people who are just
embarking on diet alone or the ketogenic
diet avatar.
Nutrition is a way that allows people to
not only calculate their macros because
people are horrible.
Calculating what they eat,
but it has an algorithm in it that if
you put in body composition changes on a
weekly basis,
it will tell you,
you know,
it will guide you step by step to your
ultimate goal.
And as far as I know,
there's another system like that.
I mean,
it's like think of weightwatchers,
but like a version like five point.
Oh,
in weightwatchers that actually works
with you.
Uh,
so I think I'm going to have all these
resources on kido nutrition.org,
but if you google any of those terms,
a kito pet sanctuary for people who have
dogs that have epilepsy or dogs that
have cancer,
look up quito,
pet sanctuary.com.
There's an ebook on there.
It's completely free.
You can download it and get the recipe
on how to put your dog food together,
uh,
that can not only prevent or help treat
cancer or seizures,
but also just get your dog as healthy as
possible.
And you know,
uh,
the charlie foundation,
I really have to give.
I acknowledged the charlie foundation in
my tedx talk and they were probably one
of the leading foundations that really
convinced me and talking with hollywood
producer,
jim abrams and,
uh,
really convinced me that the diet was
legitimate,
uh,
outside of the peer reviewed papers that
I was reading and,
uh,
and there's a movie by meryl streep
actually called first do no harm.
So meryl streep did a movie on the
ketogenic diet that most people look it
up.
It's called a first do no harm.
So meryl streep start in a ketogenetic
diet movie.
That's incredible.
And,
uh,
and it was,
that movie really floored me because I
had no idea that she did it actually.
But,
uh,
it's that movie and meeting jim,
meeting jim abrams and what the charlie
foundation is doing through a global
education is really inspired me to
pursue this path,
all the people that they're helping.
So it was so cool that I could,
I feel really blessed to be able to get
into a field of research that is in line
with what was funded to do,
which was enhance safety performance and
resilience in the warfighter.
But apply it to so many other things and
uh,
and also apply it to myself,
which is,
has been kind of a journey in and of
itself that I've really enjoyed.
Amazing stuff,
man.
And again,
thank you very much.
Thank you.
Really.
Thanks for having me.
Just,
I can't thank you enough for being here.
It just blew me away.
It was awesome.
Thank you.
All right everybody.
See ya.
Mm.